[Musique]
avec nous ce soir Johnny Hallyday
David Hallyday
Brad pitta
Matt Damon
Jean-Pierre Foucault
Gérard de Villiers
Thierry gremens et mon ami Laurent
Baffie
[Musique]
tu as l'habitude
je vous demande de vous arrêter alors
tout de suite un message pour dire c'est
pas vrai
alors ça le fait quand même quand on va
arriver Johnny Hallyday avoir 20 ans
d'interview avoir reçu la terre entière
il y a pas à dire quand tu arrives sur
le plateau ça fait le choc quand même
pour moi aussi
en fait Jenny on se connaît pas très
bien en fait moi je suis pas trop la
l'ami des stars c'est vrai je fréquente
pas beaucoup les fréquentes pas les
boîtes que tu fréquentes également
et notre première vraie rencontre en
fait c'était hier alors j'ai trouvé ça
génial hier parce que tu es arrivé avec
je crois une demi-heure de retard et tu
t'es excusé trois fois mais je trouve ça
extraordinaire on avait rendez-vous à 3h
et je suis arrivé à 3h30 j'aime pas
arriver en retard tu sais avant
j'arrivais toujours en retard
pas une demi-heure en retard mais deux
heures en retard je confondais mais
l'heure du rendez-vous avec l'heure de
départ de chez moi
et puis quand j'ai commencé à faire du
cinéma le premier jour je suis arrivé en
retard j'avais toute l'équipe qui était
là en stand by qui attendait quand je
suis arrivé me regarder m'ont rien dit
et je me sens je me suis senti tellement
mal que je suis toujours arrivé en
avance après il y a des trucs sur les
pompes ça gêne pas à l'image quoi il y a
des tâches il a dû marcher dans la
flotte bouge pas
ici on tire vraiment les pompes dis moi
tu m'as dit hier que tu regardais
souvent l'émission Tout le monde en
parle le samedi soir sur ton grand
placement géant là je regarde souvent et
que Mathilde seignait tu penses quoi du
vert du plateau là ça donne mauvaise
mine
le vert donne mauvaise mineure
là ça va en bonne forme ça va ouais t'es
revenu en début de semaine d'une cure
Laurence ça peut t'intéresser de
biontologie ah oui c'est debout à 6h
avec un lavement
c'est une science qui s'intéresse au
vieillissement psycho physique hein
c'est ça c'est un peu de la médecine
chinoise et on voit un petit peu tout ce
qui va pas dans ton corps que ce soit le
foie les intestins
era les poumons les abats quoi
encore un groupe célèbre conseil
parce que c'est un truc pour rajeunir
donc avec Laetitia un jour c'est qu'il
est ici Laetitia Laeticia Hallyday
tu connais pas sa femme j'avais une
native
elle a le dans là c'est chiant écrit en
plus
[Musique]
David ça va Johnny ouais
David Hallyday vient souvent
[Musique]
Laura ça va j'avais Mazarine merci
alors maintenant je vais me faire
plaisir
non je vais me faire ma ma musique story
Johnny Hallyday c'est à dire qu'il y en
a énormément de titres c'est très
compliqué j'ai fait un effort surhumain
j'en ai choisi 10 c'est mes 10 préférée
voilà en avant Didier je suis né oui je
suis né dans la vie dans la vie
ouais maintenant je ne vis plus haut les
murs sont toujours pris mon nom est en
argent et ma guitare est en or mes
chansons d'hier sont bien les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui mais quand la nuit arrive
je retourne dans la rue lorsque je suis
né dans la rue je suis né dans la rue
je t'aime que je t'aime que je t'aime
que je t'aime que je t'aime
toute la musique que j'aime
elle vient de là elle vient du blues
les mots ne sont jamais les mêmes
pour exprimer ce qu'elle blouse
Gabriel
tu brûle mon esprit ton amour étrange ma
vie
et l'enfer
devient comme un espoir car dans tes
mains je meurs chaque soir
je veux partager autre chose que l'amour
dans ton lit
j'ai oublié de
vivre
j'ai oublié le
ni Elle m'oublie
Elle m'oublie
m'oublier
[Musique]
on a tous quelque chose en nous de
Tennessee
cette volonté de prolonger la nuit
ce désir fou
de vie
serait
qu'attendent je ne suis pas
et attends de fois ce qu'on dit
je ne te dirai pas allumé
allumer
le feu et voir tranquillement
alors maintenant Johnny comme c'est la
première fois que que je te reçois je
vais te faire une interview première
fois
[Musique]
alors Johnny ton premier nom tout le
monde croit que c'est se mettre en fait
c'est clair comme Julien c'est le nom de
ta mère parce que ton père était assez
volage il a attends moi j'ai Claude
Moine non
c'est vrai ton père était quelqu'un de
la semaine pas tellement fait pour la
pas tellement fait pour la pour la vie
de famille et quelques jours après ta
naissance il a vendu les meubles il a
vendu même la neuillette 10 jours après
la naissance il grandit vite et huit
mois plus tard il a quitté le domicile
conjugal et donc ta mère s'est retrouvé
comme ça toute seule et elle l'a
retrouvé un an après elle est obligé à
l'épouser mais ton vrai nom ton vrai
premier nom c'est clair c'était même
c'était Huguette clair
jusqu'au mariage oui c'est jusqu'au
mariage de ma mère c'était clair qui
était mannequin chez fat une très jolie
femme qui vit toujours et qui vit
toujours
[Musique]
je crois qu'elle est bien réussi quand
même comme quoi pendant des
c'est vrai que c'est un peu un voyou
mais bon être la maman de Johnny elle
doit être fière oh je vais donner du
tracas oui mais bon c'est faire bien du
souci alors ce père Léon Smet donc
Johnny vous le reverrez 20 ans plus tard
vous vous avez 21 ans faites votre
service militaire en Allemagne et un
jour il y a un mec qui vous dit il faut
aller à l'entrée de la caserne on vous y
allez c'est un ordre vous y allez et à
ce moment-là vous voyez un type qui se
jette sur vous en disant Johnny Johnny
mon fils et on vous mettant un ours en
peluche dans les bras et c'était votre
père
et quelques années plus tard vous
apprendrez qu'en fait c'était un coup
qu'il avait monté avec les paparazzi
oui mais enfin bon ça c'est le passé et
je préfère pas trop parler de ça quoi
parce que vous l'avez vachement aidé
après quand même votre père non oui
enfin j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu mais
c'était pas toujours facile parce que
j'avais pris un appartement et puis je
reçois des coups de téléphone dans la
nuit comme quoi il avait mis le feu dans
l'appartement
j'ai essayé beaucoup de choses et puis à
un moment donné j'ai baissé les bras
quoi un message pour dire que tu me
piques mes vannes
Cerruti d'aller les revendre quand vous
louez un appartement il mettait le feu
effectivement donc c'était assez
désespérant finalement
Reggiani vous a parlé de lui une fois un
jour je rencontrais Johnny qui me dit tu
sais je sais que tu as eu de mauvaise
impressions de ton père mais moi
j'allais prendre des cours tous les tous
les weekends à Bruxelles chez lui
c'était un professeur d'art dramatique
extraordinaire
cette histoire faisait un petit peu
déboussolée d'une certaine façon cette
envie que vous avez eu après de créer
une famille et de pas y arriver c'est
peut-être dû à ça finalement sans faire
de la psychanalyse à deux balles c'était
ça l'histoire non il faut d'abord avant
de créer une famille il faut tomber sur
la bonne personne j'étais jamais tombé
sur la bonne personne
et cette fois-ci bon cette fois-ci je
crois que je suis bien tombé ouais ça a
l'air tomber ça une femme extraordinaire
avec qui je suis très heureux et bel et
il était temps parce que
première guitare
quel âge
va avoir 12 ans ouais vous étiez à Rome
avec vos cousins
destin et lit et vous avez à ce
moment-là rencontré un guitariste de
flamenco il faisait une tournée
théâtrale à cette époque là où il y
avait comme ça des tas de numéro de de
musical il y avait des gitans il y avait
des acrobates bon et il y avait dans la
troupe des gitans il y avait un
guitariste flamenco qui m'a appris à
jouer un peu de guitare et la Rota la
retard et plein de choses et ça m'a
vraiment plu et ensuite on m'a acheté
une guitare donc avec des classiques
premier rôle au cinéma 1954
vous aviez il y avait une petite annonce
dans en France Soir et comme il y a pas
de blé à la maison votre temps de vous
avez emmener la barre j'avais pas cher à
casting vous avez pris ouais dans l'état
dans la classe d'enfants mais j'étais la
Fédération c'était pas un rôle j'avais
deux phrases à dire qui a été coupées
donc ça donne pas de très bon mais on
vous voit dans le film vous vous laver
les dents vous savez ça
alors premier cachet de Johnny Hallyday
en 1955 à Hanovre premier caché c'est un
Coca-Cola vous aviez chanté Davy
Crockett sur scène
tu te souviens de cette chanson de les
croquettes David
j'ai chanté en duo avec Johnny
mais vous êtes monté très très tôt sur
les planches là enfin c'est ce qu'on
c'est ce qu'on découvre mais c'est
normal parce que j'ai été élevé par une
par une famille d'artistes qui voyageait
beaucoup qui faisait beaucoup de musique
beaucoup de cabarets donc
je voyais pas très honnêtement je me
voyais pas comptable plus tard
mais ça doit quand même perturber ça
doit être sur scène aussitôt non
comme j'en ai fait mon métier c'est
plutôt une chance parce que j'ai eu le
temps d'apprendre avant d'être connu
maintenant ce que je m'attends ce que ce
que je reproche un petit peu c'est qu'on
lance des gens on essaie de leur
apprendre à danser à chanter en 4 mois
et on les lance comme des stars ils
n'ont pas le temps ils n'ont pas ils
n'ont pas ils n'ont ils n'ont pas eu la
comment dire la formation La formation
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup Janine de
Strasbourg pour
pour aller sur une scène et d'être lancé
comme star il faut apprendre son métier
avant et on leur laisse pas le temps
d'apprendre alors effectivement quand on
les voit sans sel la première fois les
gens peuvent être peut-être déçus ce
n'est pas que le fait de chanter qui est
important c'est le fait de savoir aller
sortir d'une scène et de savoir bouger
sur une scène en fait tu es un forain
quoi
je suis un ouais en quelque sorte oui
c'est pas péjoratif non non on va pas du
tout j'adore les forêts alors première
bagarre c'était avec la bande de la
Trinité donc j'imagine il y avait du
tronc il y avait longue crise il y avait
Eddy Mitchell tirer une poignée des
dérouillés par les mecs de la bande du
sacré-cœur ou la bande de la Bastille
ils étaient plus nombreux
et c'est 200
c'était plié votre première petite amie
vous en souvenez
ma première petite amie
amie c'est Claude pechard bravo ah
en train jusqu'à l'époque vous n'aviez
pas encore de voiture alors votre
première idole c'est Brassens c'est
c'est vrai c'est que vous auriez voulu
avoir moi c'est que les grosses
moustaches
c'est une de vos premières idoles et
vous dites s'il avait fait du rock il
nous aurait tous enterré c'est vrai
parce que il chante avec sa poésie les
il l’interprété sur scène avec l'énergie
et le désespoir
d'un rocker enfin je ne connais pas
d'autres chanteurs que Brel qui
transpirait autant et qui vomissait
avant de rentrer sur scène pas avant
hein
première boîte où tu es sorti
où tu es rentré déjà
première boîte je suis sorti alors là
je sais pas j'en ai fait beaucoup la
première à l'époque la bande de la
Trinité j'imagine non
première boîte comme propriétaire c'est
2003 et voilà 2003
pour que Johnny Hallyday et ça boite à
lui mais ça a une histoire cette boîte
que j'ai monté là on va en parler on
rallume
en fait cette boîte c'est une histoire
de cœur en fait c'est absolument c'est
j'ai rencontré
j'ai rencontré Laetitia il y a 9 ans
à Miami et
c'est drôle d'ailleurs parce que à
l'époque Jean-Rock travailler pour André
Boudou
qui est le père de Laetitia le père de
Laetitia et il me téléphone j'étais à
l'hôtel il me téléphone je devais partir
le lendemain il me téléphone me disait
que tu fais ce soir je dis rien je
connais pas à Miami me dis si tu veux on
dit l'ensemble je suis d'accord il
arrive en voiture avec Audrey Boudou
Laetitia et la femme d'André on va dîner
après on va on va
aller me laisser de Miami
et puis la soirée espace on va dans
d'autres boîtes et bon on rentre tard et
puis le lendemain je revois Laetitia et
puis je rentre sur Paris et donc je
rentre sur Paris on a continué à se
téléphoner etc et puis à moi après
Laetitia je l'ai invité il est venu à
Paris elle devait rester une semaine et
puis elle n'est jamais reparti elle
avait un billet
j'ai voulu faire j'ai voulu faire par
rapport à par rapport à l'endroit où je
lève à rencontrer je voulais faire la
boîte de nuit à Paris bien alors Johnny
on t'es pas trop de boîtes de nuit on va
faire une interview boîte de nuit
bon
alors c'est à base de questionnaire de
pouces c'est comme dans les boîtes
Johnny Hallyday qu'elle est pour vous le
comble de la misère
vite chez les autres
ça fait 20 minutes j'arrive
où aimerais-tu vivre encore
pour quelle faute as-tu le plus
d'indulgence la faiblesse
quel est ton personnage historique
favori
Robin des Bois
quelle est ta qualité préférée chez
l'homme
l'humour et chez la femme
la tendresse
qui aurait tué mais si tu n'étais pas
Johnny Hallyday
Jean Gabin
quel est ton principal défaut
je suis têtu
quel est le temps de la nature que tu
n'as pas et que tu voudrais avoir
Jean Gabin je voudrais avoir une de 30
cm
ce que tu détestes par-dessus tout
les pédophiles comment aimerais-tu
mourir
vite
quel est l'état présent de ton esprit
super bien je suis ici avec toi très
bien est-ce que tu as une devise
vivre à lessive bravo merci Aurélie
et Fernandez merci Johnny alors beaucoup
beaucoup d'emails de gens qui savaient
que tu étais là ce soir leur donne pas
dans l'email non mais en tous les cas il
y a des questions est-ce que ce portable
peut être juste
on peut dire ça commence par 06
ensuite
à vous de trouver Johnny est-ce que ça
vous a aidé d'être le père de David
Hallyday pour faire ce métier
mais c'est jamais jamais facile pour un
père de réussir dans l'ordre de son fils
Johnny quel est votre meilleur souvenir
souvenir
mon meilleur souvenirs
David et Laura
merci David Hallyday
David Hallyday bonsoir salut salut
Thierry salut Laurent je crois qu'un
rapport avec Johnny Hallyday je sais
plus où j'ai mis ça c'est l'autre
dossier
nouvelle femme nouvel enfant tout est
nouveau tout neuf to neuf
votre nouvelle femme Alexandra vous
l'avez rencontré il y a un peu plus de 2
ans
c'est vrai elle est comment
un petit peu tout ça vous avez déclaré à
son sujet quand je l'ai vu j'étais sur à
1000% que c'était elle dit pareil pour
la première
et c'est comme le dernier album c'est
toujours le meilleur
c'est la femme de ma vie j'ai la boule à
l'estomac enfin ça y est c'est là va te
faire sight quoi si la boule à l'estomac
la boule à l'estomac quand tu vois une
femme tu es très amoureux tu as la boule
à l'estomac
il y a un autre truc il y a un autre
truc quand tu rencontres comme ça
quelqu'un dont tu vas être très très
amoureux et ça l'a fait à David avec
Alexandre
c'est que l'impression de la connaître
depuis toujours voilà c'est génial quand
ça vous l'a fait ça aussi
c'est vrai que c'est bonjour
C'est vrai
commence pas toi
Méline reviens en tous les cas c'est une
bonne pioche cette Alexandra c'est
Alexandra Pastor à la 24 ans elle est
jolie elle est riche
rien parce que c'est la fille de Michel
Pastor qui est l'un des hommes
d'affaires les plus importants de la
Principauté de Monaco ce qui appartient
pas au prince lui appartient à lui non à
peu près non
tu dois être bien informé
elle est très riche
elle non mais sa famille ouais
sa mère
non je veux dire Laurent elle a une
petite maison de couture avec une
boutique à Monaco une boutique à Cannes
une boutique à Paris et voilà à quoi ça
va quoi ça va on peut l'appeler
un mec qui a pas le portable de sa femme
tu sais ce qu'elle fait là non pas du
tout non ah oui tu lui fais confiance
c'est le début en même temps ouais tu
sais toujours au début on fait confiance
un peu alors il y a eu donc le grand
mariage ça a été le grand mariage de
l'été le 3 juin
le 3 juin donc toute la famille était là
sauf Laetitia votre belle-mère
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est un peu
dommage
ouais c'est dommage bien sûr c'est
dommage mais tu as envie de toute la
famille soit là et tout c'est vrai que
apparemment à ce moment là il y avait
des petits soucis donc mais je pense que
tout le monde le sait puis si long
annoncé donc c'était la grossesse
difficile ouais voilà exactement mais
vous c'est quand même pas le grand amour
avec votre belle-mère qui à moi pourquoi
non pas du tout non non on est tous
pourquoi vous dites ça il aime bien
[__] la merde
pas du tout non pourquoi non je sais pas
ça va ça va bien non ça va très bien il
va te [__] la paix
tout va bien on s'entend tous bien on a
de la chance d'être une famille bien que
si tu veux un petit peu séparer par
rapport le par la vie si tu veux on est
tous assez Unis finalement donc vous
n'étiez pas très favorable David
Hallyday de voir votre père s'engager
dans cette aventure de l'Amnesia
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours tendance à
dire qu'il faut aller dans des métiers
qu'on connaît et c'est vrai que même si
on sort une fois de temps en temps pour
faire la bringue c'est vrai que c'est le
métier de la nuit c'est pas un métier
qu'on connaît donc il va c'est vrai qu'à
ce moment il y a demandé mon avis je lui
ai donné je lui ai dit écoute si c'était
moi j'irai pas quoi parce qu'on connaît
pas tout simplement oui on peut sortir
beaucoup sans dire exactement c'est pas
du tout la même chose alors vous êtes
exprimé aussi récemment sur l'affaire de
viol dans votre père est accusé vous
dites ça devient comme aux États-Unis
finalement
comme les gens voient qu'il y a du
pognon à prendre tout le monde attaque
tout le monde quoi bah ouais je pense
qu'on vit dans une société un petit peu
comme ça où on a l'impression que tout
est super facile donc on se dit bon
l'argent facile tout ça bon on va
attaquer puis ça ça mangera pas de pain
quoi ouais c'est grotes quoi
qu'est-ce que j'en pense de ça écoute je
pense que à partir du moment où on lit
un contrat et qu'on trouve qu'il y a des
erreurs ou des choses je pense qu'on
réagisse je pense que c'est ce qu'il a
fait maintenant c'est mon père et puis
je le soutiendrai tout bannir dans tout
ce qu'il fait maintenant c'est vrai que
on a souvent posé et toi et toi et toi
moi c'est vrai j'ai de la chance moi
j'ai pas de j'ai pas pour l'instant de
souci avec eux tout se passe super bien
ça fait 18 ans que je suis dans le dans
le groupe et ils m'ont toujours soutenu
j'ai donc
décision j'espère qu'il est en tout cas
qui qu'il a pris en tout cas c'est je
pense que c'est quelque chose d'honnête
et de légitime quand il a vu quelque
chose qui lui plaisait pas il s'est dit
bon ben je vais essayer de remédier à ça
c'est pas une interview fils de
[Musique]
David Hallyday est-ce que comme
Guillaume Depardieu il vous est arrivé
de détester votre père non non jamais
est-ce que comme Harry Boulogne vous
vous êtes déjà demandé qui était
vraiment votre père
oui oui ça m'est arrivé encore
aujourd'hui des fois
est-ce que comme Jésus vous êtes arrivé
de vous prendre pour le Fils de Dieu
non non est-ce que comme laura Smet vous
avez eu envie de prendre un autre nom
oui
non mais je
non mais je me suis en fait c'est un
truc qui m'a toujours suivi depuis que
je suis né en fait j'ai découvert qu'on
m'avait appelé David Hallyday dès que
dès que je suis né ça m'a suivi toujours
est-ce que comme Michael Douglas avait
l'impression d'avoir relevé le flambeau
non
est-ce que quand Emmanuel Béart vous
pensez que vous réussirez à faire
oublier votre père
c'est vraiment pas une question que je
me pose quand même la réponse aurait ici
non non est-ce que comme Charlotte
Gainsbourg ça vous embêterait de
ressembler à votre père en vieillissant
[Rires]
encore une oh [__] magnéto Serge
ça vous embêterait de ressembler à mon
père non mais je pense qu'on se
ressemble déjà beaucoup dans on a
beaucoup de ressemblances je pense
le plus beau c'est vrai je sais pas
beaucoup plus beau je ne sais pas comme
c'est gentil merci est-ce que comme
Claude Chirac vous avez encore beaucoup
d'ambition pour votre père
ah bien sûr bien sûr mais je pense qu'on
ne cesse d'évoluer et puis de on n'a
jamais fini le travail qu'on a commencé
toute manière
est-ce que comment te dire Delon vous
êtes rendu compte que le talent n'était
pas héréditaire mais le talent le talent
n'est pas hérédité j'aime bien Anthony
c'est un mec c'est moi aussi
tu l'aimais pas est-ce que comme Paul
Belmondo vous avez déjà fait honte à
votre père au volant d'une voiture de
course
non
est-ce que comme ça le met le loup je
vous pensez que votre beau-père était
mieux que votre père
différent différents c'est bien d'avoir
les des beaux-parents différents choses
tu apprennent des trucs différents c'est
plutôt pas
maltraiani vous n'osez pas dire à votre
mère de prendre sa retraite
jamais jamais parce qu'on n'arrête pas
les passions et tant qu'on est passionné
ça ça passe ouais ça passe bien est-ce
que comme Claude François Junior faisait
déjà pensé à faire fils de votre père
comme métier
ouais c'est pas facile
non non c'est déjà été assez compliqué
d'être moi donc est-ce que comme Julie
Depardieu votre père vous a déjà
embrassé en public ouais
il avait mis la langue aussi
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille Brad Pitt
j'ai arrivé trop madame
alors
il est en train de soigner son dos il y
a des médecins qui s'occupent de lui
mais il ira bien d'ici une semaine enfin
on espère en tout cas à Paris il avait
peur de rencontrer Céline Balitrand vous
pensez non
vous restez combien de temps à Paris
vous avez prévu quelque chose ce soir
est-ce que vous avez prévu un
rendez-vous avec Nicolas Sarkozy
non non parce que Tom Cruise quand il
est venu à Paris la dernière fois il
était allé voir Nicolas Sarkozy pour
défendre sa secte de scientologie
vous savez que vous pouvez rester à
Paris tant que George bus est président
des États-Unis si vous voulez on peut
vous offrir l'asile politique
[Rires]
alors
vous allez passer une journée ici dans
cet hôtel à répondre aux mêmes questions
des journalistes français est-ce que
c'est pas fatigant finalement c'est
presque
ce qu'on fait ici la façon dont on
travaille ici tous ensemble en fait on
s'amuse bien on se marre c'est vrai que
finalement le temps passe vraiment vite
c'est la première vous êtes la première
personne
ne nous a fait cette offre un petit peu
plus originale
ça me rassure en tous les cas pendant
l'interview si vous voulez faire un
petit break si vous voulez vous
dégourdir les jambes boire un verre
de Ocean's Twelve quand vous avez reçu
le scénario brade tout de suite vous
avez eu envie de faire le film
immédiatement
donc sur le plan contractuel je ne
pouvais pas échapper à cette corvée pour
la suite est-ce que c'est vrai que tu te
Brad Pitt
là vous demandez au scénariste de
diviser
l'escroc américain par 11 puisque au
départ c'était deux deux voleurs
simplement
c'est toujours pas Brad qu'on donne du
café et aux amis de droit disons pas
laissé tomber
à Paris évidemment
en tous les cas il semble que les
acteurs se soient bien amusés ensemble
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter le
bras de cette note de service que vous
avez dictée au sujet de George Clooney
et ensuite il s'est vengé
quelqu'un avait transmis une note à
l'équipe italienne
disons qu'elle venait de George Squeezie
et qui demandait à l'équipe de se passer
à Lyon la plante Monsieur Daniel océan
pendant tout le tournage sur l'écran et
ailleurs et merci de coopération pour
que le personnage puisse retrouver
plutôt pour que l'acteur puisse trouver
le personnage bon tournage
quelqu'un aurait diffusé donc cette note
alors la vérité c'est George il se prend
vraiment pour la
différence on l'a perdu c'est de dire
que George était vraiment il était parti
il se prenait pour gagner océan ce qui
s'est passé qui est incroyable c'est
donc Brad fait passer une note en disant
Clooney il faut l'appeler Ocean parce
que sinon il faut vraiment être très
différent avec lui et ensuite de retour
à Los Angeles
George Clooney c'est vengé de Brad Pitt
en mettant un autocollant sur votre
voiture alors il y en avait deux
autocollants le premier c'était je suis
gay et je vote mais le deuxième c'était
oui
le deuxième c'était petit pénis à bord
smallpénis
drôle alors lequel sur le tournage
lequel a fait le plus de conneries
de faire c'est de se concentrer sur le
fait qu'il faut aider Georges parce que
en fait il est tombé de la falaise il
est tombé dans le gouffre
de s'approprier le personnage de Dany et
donc on lui lance une bruit de sauvetage
pour essayer de le ramener un peu tu te
souviens quand il disait ça me
profondément dans l'océan
et il croit vraiment qu'il est le mari
de Julia Roberts
psychologues qui sont en train de
s'occuper de lui et maintenant 24 heures
sur 24 mais bon ça ira ça pose problème
sur le tournage qui avait le plus grand
Carlos
lequel a été le plus payé sur le
tournage
lequel lequel lequel a été le plus radin
il faut choisir quelqu'un ce serait
toujours
c'est vrai qu'il vous a fait payer la
location de sa villa au lac de Côme
et puis deux semaines plus tard on
reçoit la facture
alors quand vous étiez en Europe lequel
avait le plus de succès dans la rue
lequel a trompé sa femme pendant le
tournage
lécher le pénis de sa femme
dit que si on lit la Bible c'est pas
dans la Bible et donc c'est pas trompé
les différences de culture entre un
continent et un autre en France c'est
pas trompé non et chez vous c'est trompé
pourquoi vous vivez pas en France non
non c'est pas trompé
c'est pas faux du tout ça
lequel s'est fait draguer par des mecs
pendant le tournage
avant le tournage
lequel est d'accord pour faire oceans
bah oui tout le monde reviendra c'est
sûr d'accord
vous êtes ce qu'on appelle des stars
d'Hollywood est-ce que le fait d'être
une star d'Hollywood ça aide avec les
filles
c'est un aphrodisiaque ça rapporte ça
rapporte beaucoup
d'argent
il faut faire quoi comme études pour
être star d'Hollywood
quand on est une star d'Hollywood est-ce
que c'est vrai qu'on peut exiger un jet
privé pour entrer dîner le soir à la
maison
on peut refuser d'assister aussi des
Oscars parce qu'on a un truc mieux à
faire ce jour-là
ceci étant peut être une star de niveau
des et malgré tout on en est pas moins
homme est-ce que quand on est une star
d'Hollywood il arrive que quand on est
sur la plage on rentre le ventre
l'interdiction a été levée donc c'est
bon je peux y retourner maintenant je
vous demande pas à vous si vous rentrez
le vendre quand vous allez sur la plage
parce que vous avez pas de ventre
vous avez des producteurs ils ont ce
mélange les cigares
ça c'est vrai est-ce que vous commencez
à perdre vos cheveux non non
est-ce que le matin quand vous vous
réveillez des fois vous avez vraiment
une haleine de poney
comme nous
moi
ce weekend
en fait
c'est vraiment bizarre c'est le paradoxe
d'ailleurs parce que une fois que vous
êtes arrivés à un point vous pouvez vous
permettre de vous acheter tout ce que
vous voulez finalement tout est gratuit
est-ce que des fois quand même vous
regardez le foot à la télé en buvant de
la bière comme nous
est-ce qu'il vous arrive de pisser dans
le lavabo
alors Brad vous avez été élu plusieurs
fois l'homme le plus sexy du monde
enfin George aussi vous savez
le même problème alors en fait depuis
puisque l'Académie a été sympa avec nous
on essaie de le lui rendre alors on a
ouvert une école pour les nouveaux les
nouveaux sexes symboles Matt a fait une
très bonne campagne cette année mais lui
on s'appliquant un peu de Jerry et un
peu de mal il y aura le prix cette
année-là
quand on est l'homme le plus sexy de la
planète on est aussi l'homme le plus
harcelé de la planète comment vous vivez
ça Brad World là
il faut se balader Iconito avec avec des
déguisements il faut pas être pris dans
une situation compromettante parce que
sinon évidemment la on perd son titre
c'est comment c'est difficile mais si
jamais ça arrivait
par exemple on verra ce que comment le
jeu de s'entend cette année
moi je me vois un peu comme un deuxième
couteau remplaçant potentiel donc si
vraiment il perd son titre moi il y a
pas de problème je peux prendre la
relève c'est vrai vous lisez jamais les
tabloïdes vous lisez pas les articles
qui vous concernent dans cette presse là
la princesse scandale donc
j'ai gagné pas mal d'argent d'ailleurs
en faisant ça donc ouais on s'est bien
marré alors Matt vous avez vous avez
cessé de fumer en seulement trois
séances d'hypnose
après 16 ans de de cigarettes est-ce que
vous allez arriver à persuader Brad Pitt
de le faire à son tour
de la personne qui m'a guéri donc
vous avez déclaré en parlant de Brad
Pitt si j'étais homosexuel il serait en
poster dans ma chambre vous êtes
vraiment amoureux de lui
vous avez pas peur maths que cela rentre
jaloux votre votre ami Ben Affleck non
non
préférence au fait qu'on parlait de de
lui et moi qui était au lit et c'était
pendant une interview il nous a dit ah
bah écoute regarde si on était vraiment
gay tous les deux on aurait une photo de
prise avec Brad et puis ensuite on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y a un certain nombre
de photos de bras sur son mur à lui donc
je vais pas parler récemment donc je
sais pas mais vous avez déclaré quand
même en parlant de Ben Affleck que
finalement vous vous histoires d'amour
n'auraient jamais plus longtemps que 2
ans et demi et que vous vous verriez
bien finir votre vie en compagnie de Ben
Affleck c'est vrai ça ou c'était juste
parce que le magazine c'était avocate
donne vous avez déclaré je me sens
frustré parce que la plupart des
écrivains blancs ne font pas leur
recherche sur l'expérience noire les
scénaristes écrivent pour des acteurs
qui rapportent des frites et les acteurs
qui rapportent du fric sont sont souvent
des blancs bien entendu le souffrait
comment accomplir ce rituel à Satan et
je crois que ça m'a vraiment beaucoup
aidé alors en France il y a un problème
il y a pas beaucoup de d'acteurs noirs
dans l'équipe est-ce que vous auriez un
conseil à leur donner pour prendre la
place qui leur revient dans la société
française
je crois que si les Noirs se mettaient
ensemble et détruisez tout industrie ce
serait parfait je plaisante je plaisante
pas qu'on vous refuse quoi que ce soit
merci
non vous êtes au carré
je suis au carré avec
j'aime bien ça
avec qui êtes-vous Laurent des gens que
je ne connais pas je j'ai reconnu Annie
Lemoine qui est carrément au topless et
bon là les gens commencent à rire mais
sinon c'est assez plombé les gens
s'emmerdent grave Thierry mais Laurent
est-ce qu'au moins vous pouvez leur
demander s'ils ont envie d'aller voir ce
film qui ressemble
envie d'aller voir ce film
c'est vrai et nous il y a un côté
gélules
c'est c'est on peut le dire quel est ton
prénom Nicolas quel est ton nom de
famille Dupont-Aignan
comment il le dira tout à l'heure il est
pudique pour l'instant
Nicolas et quand je suis au fil non il
adore les huîtres il adore les huîtres
il collectionne les coquillages
c'est toi qui me l'avais appris quelques
années c'est aussi ça l'humour à vous
cognac
il est très entouré c'était un ministre
très très connu très aimé il est là seul
comme un pestiféré et j'espère que quand
il sera président il sera reconnaître
les amis qu'il avait ce qu'ils avancent
lui notre affection fais-lui un gros
poutou
Laurent tout à l'heure fais un bisou
Laurent poupée d'abord
qui n'est pas bon ici c'est le buffet
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe Laurent
tout le monde ici respecte l'abbé Pierre
mais de là à le prendre comme traiteur
on dit non
de France à côté de vous Christophe
dans l'avion ah oui d'accord j'ai pas
dit ma fiche c'est la fille c'est la
sœur du roi Laurent c'est la sœur du
héritier du trône de France la sœur
d'Henri de France grosse fortune ou pas
il y a 50 ans ils avaient un milliard de
l'époque maintenant ils ont 70 millions
voilà tout le dos maintenant à toi de
voir ce que tu fais reportage
c'est une princesse de toi
c'est une famille royale et alors enfin
ça se fera prendre une part tu peux pas
faire ça alors on a rien fait Thierry
qui a donné de demander l'antenne c'est
pas bien tu n'as aucun respect pour
cette vieille race capétienne
il a dit c'est pas gentil à vous Laurent
reviens ici tout de suite d'accord
[Applaudissements]
voici Diane de France
bonsoir
heureux de vous avoir sur le plateau de
Tout le monde en parle
ma fille a pas été trop désagréable tout
à l'heure non personne désagréable merci
de vous
[Applaudissements]
si tu dis voilà c'est bien de laisser
une une place entre vous deux
bien alors John de France princesse
d'Orléans duchesse de Wurtenberg
Stéphane Bern vous consacre un ouvrage
publié chez Flammarion et qui s'intitule
Diane de France la princesse rebelle
voilà donc nous avons avec nous
pas la babouche bien vous êtes né le
dimanche de Pâques 1940 au Brésil car
votre père le conte de Paris devant la
montée de la guerre devant la montée des
périls avait envoyé toute la famille au
Brésil pour la mettre à l'abri voilà et
vous êtes né à Petropolis exactement à
quelques quoi sans bornes de Rio de
Janeiro c'est ça
c'est dans la montagne c'est un peu le
Versailles brésilien
comparaison de Versailles c'est très
beau hein
du Brésil voilà alors votre mère était
là donc déjà quand vous arrivez et parce
que votre mère écoute
c'est l'inverse
on en a eu des culs de portée mais
vous connaissez à Pétropolis dans le
Versailles brésilien j'espère que mes
amis téléspectateurs qui regardent cette
émission pour se cultiver suivre ce que
je dis il regarde sur la carte où est
Métropolis absolument alors quand la
guerre commence votre père s'engage
incognito dans la Légion étrangère sous
le nom de Aurillac mais il est
démobilisé évidemment en 40 quand il y a
l'armistice il s'installe au Maroc où il
devient l'héritier du trône de France à
la mort de son propre père c'est comme
ça que ça se passe voilà alors à
l'époque la loi d'exil interdit aux
familles ayant régné sur la France de de
vivre en France donc vous êtes en exil
au Maroc vous êtes élevé comme une
espèce de petite sauvage jaune on
pourrait dire
je crois que c'était dans moi-même
sauvageonne parce que mais c'est pas
l'éducation n'a pas été sauvageonne du
tout on a une éducation très stricte ce
qui est très bien pour plus tard mais je
crois que c'est mon caractère qui
sortait de là et j'étais intitulé par
tout ceux de la famille la sauvage le
vilain petit canard
calme-toi voilà donc vous vivez au Maroc
cette prime en France ensuite l'Espagne
à Pampelune et le Portugal dans le dans
la maison de votre père la Quinta voilà
il a
qu'est-ce qui se passe là vous entrez en
rébellion contre pratiquement la terre
entière et vous dites très jeune
personne ne décidera à ma place la
couleur de mes pulls
personne ne désirera à partir
d'aujourd'hui ce que je vais faire de ma
vie et moi je décide moi-même ce que je
veux faire et c'est ça qui m'a fait que
la psy était pas très contente pas très
contente d'ailleurs
été rebelle après le passage chez la psy
effectivement on l'a mis dans une
institution pour handicapé mentaux oui
bah oui parce que si tu veux là à cette
époque là ça rigolait pas une seconde
et là vous étiez avec des enfants qui
étaient du tout incapable de reconnaître
une pomme d'un chat
j'avais beaucoup de peine pour
moi je prenais les coups de bâton pour
parce que j'avais trop de peine mais
comme petite fille de 9 ans qui prend
des coups de bâton pour les les autres
ça dure une deux semaines et après j'ai
dit moi je veux plus continuer à te
prendre des coups de bâton mais ça me
faisait de la peine alors à l'issue de
ce séjour dans cette institution pour
pour handicapé mentaux vous rompez
carrément avec votre famille vous vous
ne voulez plus les voir
non
vous comprenez
étant donné qu'on est on a un timbre sur
nous on nous décrète imbécile idiot moi
je dis pas c'est très bien à partir
d'aujourd'hui moi je vais encore plus
que à partir de là vous êtes élevé et
vous êtes élevé par des domestiques
adorable venez du Limousin j'ai lu
chanter la Madelon alors c'était pas
très correct non plus elle disait
princesse dire mais on fait pas ça elle
m'a éduqué elle est adorable et je
j'allais avec les ouvriers dans
l'affaire au fond je suis chez rien vous
êtes élevé par les domestiques et en
1950 l'Assemblée nationale approche la
loi d'exil vous rentrez en France je
finis par rentrer et là quand vous allez
dans une école française vous êtes
victime alors là du passé historique de
votre famille dans la cour d'école les
enfants vous crient Orléans assassin oui
oui alors moi j'étais furieuse parce que
je dis comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent
vous voulez dire que mon père est un
assassin enfin on l'a porté tout ce qui
s'est passé des rois de France mais je
trouve que c'était injuste c'est un
juste moi une fois j'ai vu un panneau
énorme Orléans 80 km je n'y ai pas cru
mais ça c'est plus court
quand même c'est quand même des
dénonciations tout le temps
de Diane Philippe Égalité a voté la mort
de son cousin Louis XVI je sais pas si
toi tu voterais la mort de ton cousin
oui non
et ensuite
Louis-Philippe a chassé Charles X son
cousin deux fois de suite
à l'école vous tombiez sur des enfants
c'est vrai mais vous n'avez pas besoin
d'attaquer le nom de mon père moi je
défendais quand même mon père mais vous
comprenez quand même que que des enfants
aient pu vous dire ça à l'époque chez
les parents qui leur ont dit ça c'est
pas eux qui étaient partisans
c'est un espèce de stupidité de racisme
contre les en l'air en tous les cas vous
êtes fait insulter à l'école qu'est-ce
que vous faites à 19 ans vous épousez le
duc de faire tomber
le problème c'est que votre frère a dit
parce que lui il a aussi épousé une
burtenberg votre frère Henri qui est
donc maintenant l'héritier du trône a
dit que c'était des mariages à ranger
tout ça non c'est absolument pas vrai
lui il était fou amoureux de Alyssa je
peux vous le dire parce que quand on a
l'air en chemin il fallait toujours
s'arrêter pour téléphoner à cette époque
il y avait pas les mobiles ma belle-sœur
qui s'appelle Marie-Thérèse alors il
téléphone et moi j'ai jamais arrête de
téléphoner fiche nous la paye
emmène-nous là où on veut donc en fait
c'est pas vrai mais non votre mariage
n'a pas été arrangé pour réconcilier
parce que vous savez bien quand même que
ça aidait à la réconciliation
franco-allemande ça fait du un boomer
que des
aristocrates français épouser des
aristocrates allemands c'était bien ah
oui c'était très bien pour la politique
vous seriez prête à vous appuyer en
Elton John en
quoi voilà
c'est autre chose
alors le problème quand même faut le
dire c'est que la vie chez levure
tenberg c'était pas très très drôle
c'est pas facile à prononcer déjà
vous arrivez à Zurich il a même pas
réservé une chambre d'hôtel le mec
franchement on a fait tout oublier
franchement vous êtes obligés de dormir
dans un bouge oui oui camping
c'est là vous êtes formidable je vous a
fait rire
le lendemain j'ai retrouvé toute la
famille à l'aéroport ça a été de nouveau
de l'embrassables bon déjà tu as le mec
il est sur ma vie il y a eu des choses
ce livre montre que c'est une femme qui
a passé par des hauts et des bactéries
mais à chaque fois grâce à son humour
et elle rigole de la plus importante des
bêtises qu'on me faisait et des mauvais
choix
il y a pas eu de c'est dans le livre
c'est vous qui l'avez des croquis
technique
bien alors après il y a un épisode un
petit peu tragique sérieusement c'est le
voyage de noce donc vous êtes à Rio vous
rencontrez une diseuse de Bonaventure
qui vous qui vous tire qui vous tire les
cartes et qui vous annoncent la mort de
votre frère François qui est mort en
héros en Algérie on s'en souvient tous
et c'est un petit peu le début du déclin
de la famille d'Orléans on peut le dire
quoi la mort de Françoise c'est un oui
choc pour papa et maman nous tous aussi
moi aussi c'était mon héros comme je dis
dans le livre et là vous découvrez un
petit peu quand même
votre père quoi si vous êtes très déçu
par votre père par exemple il avait
promis une date pour vous il l'a pas
payé quoi c'est dur ça on a beau avoir
de l'humour la situation de ma
belle-famille envers moi avec Norman mon
père petit oh mais très bien très bien
très bien ça donnerait une tente et puis
j'en ai jamais vu la couleur bon
qui avait été promis par votre père il
avait dit
et le non ce qui s'est passé
les frais du mariage et Henri votre père
n'a rien donné voilà donc vous quand
vous étiez face à cette famille des
vertèbres c'était très compliqué pour
vous
c'était gênant parce qu'on on était un
peu comme un coucou qui viendra
c'est un peu embêtant d'ailleurs il vous
mène la vie dure c'est Würtenberg c'est
pas facile pour vous vous avez des
problèmes et puis je parle pas la langue
voilà
vous partez c'est un petit peu la
boulette mais je crois comme vous en
parlez comme vous en avez tellement
tellement
je crois que vous en parlez dans le
livre donc on peut en parler c'est un
petit peu réjouir
alors nous vous savez on attaque
personne non simplement alors Laurent tu
sois que tu sois Laurent que tu sois au
courant
Diane par seul en Espagne
en Espagne
c'est congés payés alors voilà la phrase
j'ai trouvé le réconfort sur l'épaule
compatissante d'homme
merde fusty le roi prince ou simple
anonyme
vous êtes content non on n'est pas
content non on n'est pas c'est la vie
qui a passé les planches
moi ma femme partirait en congés payés
comme vous dites avec des rois des
princes voir de simples
pour toujours
et voilà qu'on se parle
non honnêtement vous avez eu de la
chance permettez-moi de vous le dire
j'ai de la chance de tomber sur un homme
Carl qui a une certaine grandeur
un grand seigneur
peut-être qu'un jour vous l'aurez ici
mais j'espère mais c'est dommage qu'ils
soient pas venus
je te raconte pas les fiches qu'il a
c'est un désastre bon donc il passe
l'éponge hein alors allons au fait il
passe l'éponge il vous pardonne
sans problème en combien de temps
le pardonne
je vois pas pourquoi faire du blablabla
je suis arrivé j'ai dit écoute voilà je
reviens et bien tout le monde d'abord
je suis là tout le monde tout le tout le
monde du château les enfants tout le
monde n'ont qu'une envie que je revienne
parce que il faut voir que quand je suis
parti les dames doivent le savoir quand
on quitte la maison bah c'est le bordel
après dans la maison
que finalement je faisais quelque chose
donc il était content de pouvoir revenir
finalement alors ils étaient tous
contents une question c'est pas dans le
livre ça c'est pas dans le livre est-ce
que vous êtes reparti ensuite en congés
payés non ça c'est bien
donc il vous a pardonné une fois mais
après vous avez plus jamais fait d'écart
Diane bon d'accord ok c'est bon ok c'est
bon pas Malte avec des épaules c'était
pas Louis t'as raison
n'est peut-être pas trompé une épaule on
peut dire que c'est pas grave une épaule
alors une épaule pour
ça vous fait quoi de France de voir
qu'aujourd'hui les châteaux servent à
tourner la Star Academy
ou des films de cul
bon et ben c'est une époque qui était
évolue et qui finit et vous en prenez
votre parti quoi et ça vous fait quoi de
devoir que Stéphanie Monaco épouse un
acrobate portugais par exemple ça c'est
sympa
vous êtes choqué parce que vous vous
avez posé un burtenberg quand même
le gouvernement portugais a démenti
c'est pour te dire à quel point c'est
grave gouvernement portugais a dit qu'il
était pas portugais
c'est bon c'est quoi par exemple de voir
que Jérôme le roi est obligé de jouer à
Guingamp
er
et que le futur roi d'Italie épouse une
roturière ça vous fait quoi ça fait
bizarre quand même
et les princes de luxe pas toi
bien alors le bouquin s'appelle Diane de
France princesse rebelle et on va voir
si vous êtes une vraie rebelle interview
rebelle
[Musique]
interview rebelle Laurent Diane de
France est-ce que vous avez déjà dit des
gros mots
vous avez déjà dit des gros mots
est-ce que vous avez déjà porté un jean
voir si vous êtes rebelle oui est-ce que
vous avez déjà
fêté le 14 juillet
pas souvent c'est arrivé c'est quand
même nous qui l'avons provoqué le 14
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez déjà
fait l'amour sans désir de procréer
non
mais non six enfants et il a fait
l'amour 6 fois je crois que le compte
est bon les lettres ah est-ce que vous
avez déjà mis des coudes sur la table et
là là là
est-ce que vous avez déjà embrassé une
personne de votre sexe
est-ce que vous avez déjà embrassé votre
sexe
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Pierre Foucault
Jean-Pierre Foucault voilà
merci
alors
viens alors Jean-Pierre vous êtes l'une
des plus grandes stars de la télévision
française vous êtes célèbre pour votre
bonhomie pour votre bonne humeur mais
derrière ce sourire se cacher des larmes
et c'est ce que l'on apprend à la
lecture de le sourire aux larmes qui est
publié chez Kalman Levy en fait ce qu'on
apprend en lisant ce livre Jean-Pierre
c'est que votre famille a été victime de
deux grands événements historiques qui
ont marqué la seconde moitié du 20e
siècle la deuxième guerre mondiale et la
guerre d'Algérie alors on va prendre les
choses dans l'ordre chronologique on va
commencer par la par la guerre et là on
apprend que vous êtes juif Jean-Pierre
Jean-Pierre Foucault et juif par votre
mère dont le vrai nom en fait est fait
ça et non pas Paula pesa Lesca elle
vient d'une famille juive polonaise qui
ont fui ce pays face à la montée de
l'antisémitisme alors en fait cette
famille
vivait en Pologne dans une ville appelée
molden et devant les actes de vandalisme
dont étaient victimes les commerces
tenus par des Juifs devant les
humiliations et les agressions dans des
victimes les personnes physiques
beaucoup sont partis certains sont allés
en Amérique du Sud ou en Palestine
d'autres en France ou en Belgique et
votre votre mère donc pessa à l'époque
va en vers où elle rejoint sa soeur Anna
elle va envers c'était la seule solution
pour elle c'était la seule personne
qu'elle connaissait hors de ses
frontières quand les nazis envahissent
la Belgique ils partent à Paris c'est
l'exode quoi sur les routes c'est une
suite on quitte la Pologne parce qu'il y
a le presseur on quitte la Belgique on
arrive en zone libre elle est occupée on
fuit c'est une fuite en avant alors en
fait la soeur de votre mère et son mari
eux rentrent de Paris en Belgique mais
mais votre mère continue elle veut aller
en Argentine rejoindre des cousins
qu'elle a là-bas elle veut embarquer à
Marseille elle descend à conseil et
c'est là que son destin bifurque
complètement puisqu'elle rencontre votre
père Marcel Foucault alors là plus
question de plus question d'Argentine
ben non parce que l'amour l'amour a pris
le dessus et en fait l'Argentine s'est
arrêté au port de Marseille et ça n'est
qu'après la guerre en fait que votre
mère apprendra que sa sœur Anna qu'elle
avait rejoint en verre et est morte dans
le camp de birknot et que elle est la
seule survivante parmi 11 membres de sa
famille elle savait qu'elle partait elle
savait qu'elle partait pour les camps
puisque un jour elle est allée à Lyon
elle savait qu'elle était dans un des
trains qui partait pour birkena et la
couru sur le quai de la gare Lyon
Perrache en criant connaissez-vous Anna
connaissez-vous Anna pour lui dire
qu'elle avait sauvegardé les enfants de
sa sœur elle ne l'a pas vu sa sœur ne
l'a pas entendu mais elle était vraiment
dans ce train puisque par la suite sur
les listes que elles ont découvertes
après guerre elle a appris que sa sœur
était là mais l'essentiel l'essentiel
dans cette tristesse et ce malheur avec
mon père et ma mère est sauvé ses deux
jeunes enfants de 7 et 8 ans Maurice et
Paulette alors pas étonnant qu'après la
guerre votre mère est acceptée que ces
trois enfants dont vous êtes l'aîné soit
soit baptisé c'est-à-dire qu'en fait à
ce moment-là ces deux mères juives ont
mis leurs enfants sous la protection de
la foi catholique parce qu'ils se sont
dit ça risque de recommencer ça risque
de revenir c'était bien évidemment par
protection mais sans doute aussi un peu
par amour puisque mon père était
catholique pratiquant ses parents
étaient encore vivants et il a demandé
vraisemblablement et par amour et par
protection que nous soyons élevés mes
sœurs et moi-même moi d'abord parce que
je suis l'aîné dans la religion
catholique ce qui était mon cas alors
voilà les années passent vous passez vos
dimanches au lac à côté de Toulon vous
partez là-bas faire des pique-nique avec
votre Père qui est une de la haie
rutilante vous découvrez la radio vous
avez des difficultés à l'école et là
vous réalisez en fait que le spectacle
c'est peut-être votre vocation
Jean-Pierre vous aimez divertir quoi
vous vous rendez compte que ça oui parce
que je suis fasciné par des voix que
j'entends à la radio moi je trouve
magique je me dis quand il est 7h du
matin j'entends quelqu'un qui est de
bonne humeur qui me dit qu'il fait beau
qu'il fait pas beau qui me donne l'heure
et j'aimerais j'aimerai mettre un
physique un visage sur cette voie et je
me suis dit un jour peut-être
pourrais-je être à sa place il doit bien
avoir une recette pour être tous les
jours tous les jours de l'année de bonne
humeur et ça a été une de mes une de mes
patients si vous voulez à tel point que
j'avais bidouiller un petit fil qui
partait du poste de radio familiale pour
aller jusque sous mon oreiller et
j'écoutais comme ça la radio en rêvant
un jour peut-être en faire à mon tour
alors à cette époque là il y a un
épisode qui est assez drôle c'est
Jean-Pierre Foucaud défoncé avec un
produit qui s'appelle le café long
défoncer c'est pas ça n'a pas la même
connotation qu'elle a aujourd'hui
tous les deux d'ailleurs à prendre un
petit peu de dans le bon point donc vous
on vous avait donné un si j'avais su je
me serais bien en noir c'est un deuxième
point commun il se défonce aussi
un produit comme ça dans les années 70
sur les tables de l'école en expliquant
au prof comment il fallait enseigner il
m'écoutait parfois défoncer
et là ça va mieux question poids oui là
c'est ce que je vous en pose des
questions
ensuite arrive un temps un petit peu
difficile c'est le temps des difficultés
financières de votre père les déjeuners
du dimanche se sont faits plus rares la
de la RST au garage enfin voilà c'était
la c'était un peu la dèche au garage
simplement pour qu'elle tourne elle ne
sortait plus voilà alors votre père
relance ses affaires en Algérie
il ouvre un bureau rue Michelet et c'est
là qu'il sera assassiné en 1962 quelques
quelques semaines avant l'indépendance
deux balles dans le dos l'assassin n'a
jamais été identifiée jamais
jamais 22 février 1962 il est devant ses
bureaux vous avez raison du 18 rue
Michelet et il prend deux balles dans le
dos qui pourquoi je ne serai jamais mais
j'ai reçu vous savez beaucoup de
témoignages de gens qui habitaient la
rue Michelet tout le monde me dit on
tirait sur tout le monde tout le monde
tirait sur tout le monde c'était la fin
et le début de la nouvelle Algérie alors
vous racontez Jean-Pierre Foucault votre
visite à Alger rue Michelet vous marchez
dans la rue elle est longue la rue
Michelet elle commence le numéro 240
votre père était assassiné au numéro 18
donc vous descendez cette rue et avec
tous les gens qui vous disent c'est
votre dernier mot c'est votre dernier
mot alors il y a des fois ça fait
plaisir évidemment mais là d'un seul
coup ça devient j'imagine lourd quoi oui
et non parce que je m'imaginais arriver
dans un pays hostile dans le pays qui
avait pris la vie de mon père et c'était
tout le contraire parce que vous savez
Alger nous sommes très connus nous tous
Alger parce que ça n'est plus Alger la
blanche mais elle j'ai la parabole et en
descendant cette rue où je n'attendais
que ce numéro 18 pour enfin vivre avec
émotion en ce moment que j'ai attendu 42
ans c'est vrai que j'entendais c'est
votre dernier mot mais je préfère si
votre dernier mot à des à des colis B ou
des réflexions hostiles en disant
qu'est-ce qui vient faire chez nous vous
entrez au 18 rue Michelet vous posez vos
mains sur les boîtes aux lettres qui
n'ont pas changé qui sont les mêmes que
celles qui est qui avait en 62 j'imagine
j'allais dire c'est presque ma chance
rien n'a changé comme ça j'ai pu
vraiment voir 42 ans après la porte et
la même les boîtes aux lettres sont les
mêmes au fond du couloir sombre
l'ascenseur qui est en panne depuis 62
ou 63 et là dans ce couloir je croise
quelqu'un qui me dit tiens qu'est-ce que
vous faites là je lui dis en deux mots
il me dit même ma grand-mère était là en
62 montée
je monte
elle m'accueille gentiment ne comprend
pas pourquoi celui qui le voit à la télé
entre d'un seul coup chez elle
et j'attends la vérité j'attends un bout
de vérité et là elle me dit mais vous
savez nous les Arabes en 62 on habitait
pas la rue Michelet c'était un quartier
chic je suis arrivé qu'après donc elle
n'a pas vu elle n'a rien su donc pour
moi ça a été si vous voulez c'est trois
étages les plus longs de ma vie en
disant peut-être qu'au bout de la
dernière marche enfin je saurai 42 ans
après malheureusement je n'ai pas su
alors là vous avez 14 ans comme ça
arrive et c'est là que vous commencez à
vous cacher derrière votre sourire en
fait j'avais deux solutions ou tomber
dans la dépression parce que je ne
pensais qu'à ça qu'à ça qu'à ça qu'à ça
dès qu'il y avait un instant de silence
à la maison ou à l'école je ne pensais
qu'à mon père pourquoi lui par qui
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait c'est pas normal
c'était le plus français quand on
regarde son père quand on est gamin il
est grand il est fort donc la seule
solution c'était de me faire remarquer
je pouvais pas être Playboy pour les
raisons que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure donc j'ai décidé d'être clones
donc j'ai si vous voulez utiliser ce ce
masque mon livre j'aurais pu l'appeler
méfiez-vous des apparences j'ai voulu
prendre ce sourire on évite de me poser
des questions idiotes du type est-ce
qu'il te manque ton père donc là au
moins je faisais le clown les gens se
marrer et on avait oublié ma
tristesse votre tristesse et surtout ma
souffrance ma profonde souffrance je
peux vous dire quelque chose qui m'a
profondément ému j'ai mon professeur
principal que je n'avais pas vu depuis
40 ans je lui ai envoyé mon livre il m'a
appelé monsieur Ripert il m'a dit
Jean-Pierre je voulais dire quelque
chose je vous écoute monsieur le père je
l'ai lu deux fois pourquoi l'avez-vous
lu deux fois Monsieur Ripert parce que
j'ai compris qu'on ne t'avait pas
compris et ça ça m'a fait si vous voulez
énormément de bien énormément de peine à
la fois j'ai bien fait j'ai bien fait de
d'afficher mon sourire
Jean-Pierre Foucault
alors Jean-Pierre maintenant qu'on sait
que ce sourire cache des larmes
on voit que vous êtes capable de casser
votre image on va vous faire une
interview je casse mon image
[Musique]
est-ce que vous connaissez des gros mots
Jean-Pierre Foucault bien entendu que je
connais des gros mots quel est le pire
des gros mots que tu puisses prononcer
que diantre
[Musique]
bleu
peut-être tu vas trouver les gros mots
que tout le monde a coupé on est
d'accord
comme ça vous dites quoi par exemple
vous êtes vraiment énervé contre
quelqu'un vraiment un truc je je sais
plus énervez-moi pour voir tu as encore
grossi Foucault
c'est très marseillais ça
cela dit c'est vrai que tu as encore
grossi vous êtes déjà frappé une femme
non bah non bah non
non non dis la vérité une femme
ni un animal par contre un mec avec un
pull noir zippé par le devant ça peut
être
Jean-Pierre est-ce que pour casser un
peu votre image là vous pourriez nous
dire vous êtes un obsédé sexuel mais je
ne suis pas un obsédé sexuel moi j'aime
le sexe comme vous pouvez l'aimer mais
je suis pas déçu
pas dire parce qu'on est pas obsédé
sexuel que sexuellement cette comment
dirais-je
donc
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que j'ai
jamais eu de plainte jamais la drogue du
coup
rappelez le nom du produit
vous coiffer autrement mais ça m'est
arrivé regardez-moi j'ai changé
le coiffeur pendant sacrée est décidé de
me faire un truc un peu spécial ça
tellement gueuler au standard de TF1 que
le mercredi d'après je me suis coiffé
normalement
est-ce que vous pourriez faire ça ou pas
paradis qui vous emmerde ah bien
mais sauf que il ne m'emmerde pas parce
que je suis un homme événement
pour casser votre image
l'oreille de Laurent bien sûr bien sûr
qui va partir avant que ça se passe
du tout hein
Méline Jean-Pierre va te lécher
l'oreille pour casser son image viens
chéri il faudrait l'attacher
l'oreille mais juste comme ça
pourquoi attendez d'abord j'aimerais
comprendre vos pulsions
d'après des informations que j'ai pu
avoir vous concernant il semblerait
qu'il y a d'autres endroits que vous
préférez pour la lèche
après non ce matin on me réveillant je
me suis dit j'aimerais que tu me lèche
mais juste le bout de l'oreille comme ça
[Applaudissements]
bien alors géant de Villiers j'ai quand
même un compte à régler avec vous parce
que je vous ai invité ici récemment pour
votre livre consacré à la libération des
otages chez nous et malbruno en présence
de Georges malbruno
et puis j'ai lu dans un magasin moi
j'étais très sympa avec vous et vous
vous dit dans un magazine on a discuté
d'une façon très intéressante et
Ardisson se trouver un peu en dehors du
coup on parlait de trucs que lui ne
connaissait pas et le guignol habituel
c'est toi ben lui non plus je vais vous
dire moi j'avais été très sympa avec
vous parce que on va te déchirer
maintenant c'est la guerre il y a un
truc il y a un truc que je vous ai pas
dit quand vous êtes venus et je vais
vous le dire ce soir tant pis pour vous
fallait pas dire ça vous m'avez accordé
dans des centres de police il y a une
vingtaine d'années une interview c'est
pour le journal Rocket folk et vous
aviez dit dans cette interview au sujet
de l'apartheid en Afrique du Sud vous
m'aviez dit à l'époque je me sentirai
toujours plus proche
blanc con que d'un noir intelligent
je vous avais dit pourquoi et vous
m'aviez répondu parce que je suis blanc
on est toujours plus proche vous savez
les noirs sont plus proches les uns des
autres un noir et au plus proche de la
Loire que d'un blanc et ça n'a rien de
raciste c'est un une simple constatation
non mais il y a aucune chance après vous
persistez en disant je me sentirai
toujours plus proche d'un blancon que
d'un noir intelligent
je me sentirai gère mon plus proche d'un
blanc d'un noir tous les noirs sont plus
proches les uns des autres que d'un
blanc c'est logique ça vous partez ça
vous paraît pas évident non moi je me
sens plus proche d'un noir intelligent
d'un blancon on peut pas approuver ce
truc mais depuis lors de Villiers je
l'ai appris étaler en Afrique du Sud
voilà il a découvert ce qu'était
président un pays dans lequel chacun
respectait chacun tout à fait noir les
blancs les métiers les Indiens je
finalement malgré ses propos dit à 20
ans devenus à l'admirateur de Mandela
tout à fait oui parce que il y a 20 ans
vous disiez qu'il y avait eu des blancs
en Afrique du Sud avant les noirs et
qu'ils étaient plus chez eux en Afrique
du Sud que les Noirs
il y a très longtemps en Afrique du Sud
de façon qui ont fait la peau à beaucoup
de noix qui s'y trouvait notamment les
Zoulous mais c'est plus au sud c'est à
l'Afrique du Sud quand même hein
non c'est le cap bien que vous arrive de
dire des trucs bien
dans la même interview à rock et folk
qui a 20 ans toujours des centres de
police vous disiez les Pieds-Noirs
auraient pu garder l'Algérie s'il
s'était battu mais ils étaient trop
indolents ils étaient complètement
arabisés bah ils sont pas battus sauf le
reste c'était pas du c'était pas de la
bataille c'était du massacre
inutile et stupide
c'est que ils étaient indolents parce
qu'ils étaient arabisés c'est pour vous
l'arabe est indolente d'une façon
générale
écoutez la vie est pied-noir était des
gens qui vivaient dans un milieu arabe
complètement mais j'avais pris les
habits d'ailleurs si vous voyez les
pieds-noirs et les Arabes ils vivent à
peu près de la même façon les yeux
s'écoutent la façon de vivre bon c'est
normal ils ont ils ont réagi les uns sur
les autres alors vous commencez votre
carrière journalistique dans un journal
d'extrême droite mais je suis pas resté
longtemps qui s'appelle rivarole dans
votre bouquin il y a des grands passages
anti-communistes alors c'est voilà tout
à fait voilà des passages en petit droit
de le mystes aussi oui c'est parfois
agaçant car ça va trop loin voir un peu
colonialiste certains passages aussi
n'a pas apporté que du mal
c'est comme ça
c'est curieux d'ailleurs comme on
s'attache en France on a l'extrême
gauche est absolument sacrée
qu'en
2005 quelqu'un comme Arlette Laguiller
disent il faut atterrir les
licenciements personne ne dit rien tout
le monde trouve ça normal
es
vous passez par Paris presse et vous
arrivez à France dimanche et là vous
sortez ce fameux scoop Sheila est-il un
homme
non
pour cette série là descente de police
elle était encore traumatisée Serge il a
interviewé je sais pas combien d'années
après 20 ans après bon c'était pas du
tout une île méchanceté c'est tout
simplement on faisait une sur Shella
toutes les semaines à peu près à la
demande de son après-sario Claude
Carrère et puis un jour dit goujon était
le relecteur en chef on a été voir
Carrère on n'avait pas d'histoire etc et
il a eu il a dit elle venait enfin elle
peut pas avoir d'enfants
et puis il a fait la une et c'est moi
vous êtes mis une seconde à la place de
Sheila
une seconde une demi-seconde c'est
profondément scandaleuse que vous avez
fait profondément scandaleux et que vous
en riez encore je trouve ça tout à fait
mes pizzas
n'est pas monté au plafond mais monsieur
Carrère n'est pas là
pensez d'abord aux gens que vous
attaquez quand vous faites ce genre de
Pitre et vous y revenir
mais est-ce que est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte de ce que vous dites d'une
femme est-ce que vous vous rendez compte
de ce que vous dites et que vous
affichez haut et clair avec à 5 colonnes
à la une en disant une telle est un
homme c'est profondément scandaleux et
que vous riez aujourd'hui je vous
affiche mon plus profond mais plus
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il vient de coller son chewing-gum sur
la table
[Applaudissements]
mon chéri je vais leur dire dans quelle
vérité chérie ça va oui on fait ce qu'on
veut on est français
et là je pense
avoir des missions je pense toi là
là là là là là là là là là là là là oh
vas-y
assure-toi
je te rassure Clémentine
nouvelle récolte en tous les cas en tous
les cas tu amènes Debbouze et dans la
couleur orange des Ukrainiens qui se
battent c'est bien pour l'Ukraine pour
l'Ukraine
alors c'est marrant c'est marrant
[Applaudissements]
elle a raison la ligne 13 il apprend
aussi
je vous ai manqué alors depuis trois
semaines là vous voulez venir chaque
semaine
où est Laurent Baffie Laurent Baffie est
pas là ce soir
ah et les remplacer par Orange
c'est la dernière fois qu'on s'est vu il
nous a craché dessus
parce qu'on lui avait volé des trucs
chez lui alors
pardon
on va varier un peu les plaisirs parce
que la dernière fois que vous êtes venu
toi tu étais Ramzy et toi tu étais Éric
quasiment mon prénom voilà et
aujourd'hui on va faire l'inverse donc
toi tu Éric et toi tu es Ramzy j'ai que
du rire alors moi j'ai voilà
comment ça va tu me fais bien marrer
allez voyons très bien nous sommes
aujourd'hui
je suis revenu moi non non non non non
non non non
tu n'es pas toi tu es Éric comment ça va
Ramzy
ah ça va être super facile moi oh mon
dieu que faire Méric Ramzy vous êtes
parti en vacances j'ai pris des couleurs
maintenant
euh oui avec ma femme de Petrini
on s'éclate à Saint-Tropez on voit frère
vas-y on a dit pas des noms comment elle
va votre fille ma fille est là sachant
que je suis grand et ma femme est grande
va faire plus de 3 mètres ah oui il a un
problème avec sa fille ma fille est très
très grande elle fait la taille de Jamel
déjà
à 2 ans elle a 2 ans ouais c'est
incroyable ça elle vous a dit quoi ce
matin votre fille
papa tu vas encore faire rire
tu vas encore faire rire papa et bien
amuse-toi bien
de l'humour
elle est bien votre fille elle est
pardon alors j'adore être là il m'a
brûlée Éric
Eric tu m'écoutes Eric ouais
pardon Marco qu'est-ce que
mais j'ai pas compris
dites-moi
Eric vous voyez c'est moi
je pense oui que je serais bien tout
seul tout à fait ne me sert à rien du
tout
timide
je peux pas le faire
Eric
cette personne est très rouge
là il faut sortir il y a une personne de
Saint-Tropez
bonsoir non mais c'est vrai j'ai
flashé moi les couleurs ça me ah c'est
du jus de pomme ou c'est du exactement
c'est du pomme c'est de l'alcool
Eric je vois pas d'alcool je suis
islamiste
quand même
parce que quasiment de l'essence en fait
pas du tout c'est pas du tout c'est ça
c'est des produits que vous utilisez
pour préparer des choses n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi
vous êtes moitié antillais moitié
autrichien de quel peuple vous
sentez-vous le plus proche disons non
parce que je vais refaire mon accent qui
marche disons je suis d'accord
comment vous le trouvez comme comédien
Ramzy ah par contre je le trouvais
exceptionnel tout à fait j'ai rarement
vu un comédien d'une
efficacités
comme comédien
je trouve
ça veut dire c'est un grand con quoi
alors moi je te fais classe toi c'est
vrai que Ramzi est grave est-ce que vous
pourriez vous retourner
voilà non vous vous essayez à l'envers
l'interview de do vous changez d'un
concept non non c'est un petit problème
de dos j'ai mal au dos j'aime pas aussi
vous allez faire des coups de crasse
hein
vous avez tellement de présence à la
télé qu'à un moment il nous demande de
vous mettre de dos parce que sinon au
Serge caleçon
pourquoi tu fais l'animal comme ça
pourquoi tu veux faire toujours
le même
mettez-vous dedans
et pas vraiment
c'est toi qui a demandé ça non c'est pas
moi je viens juste de marquer pendant 30
ans
il est foutu sérieux genre sérieux
je pense franchement que tu vas aller
crever en enfer sincèrement
en tout cas il y aura au moins Tupac et
Coluche là-bas facile
la surprise et là c'est filmé de dos oui
c'est le premier
la surprise viens viens viens viens
viens viens viens viens viens
avec une autre meuf là-bas
est-ce que dodo est-ce que doudou vous
pouvez jouer la peur moi ça va être la
même chose
la peur dans un spectacle de Marie
prison
la danseuse classe là il fait tout le
temps ça
[Musique]
le plaisir
on se concentre mon petit Ramzi je vous
kiffe Thierry vous savez je sais on vous
propose un plan à trois qu'est-ce que
vous faites
on prend la mienne oui on a déjà joué
là-bas d'accord
c'est mignon oui moi il faut laisser ça
il y en a plus j'ai envie d'ouvrir
une femme superbe coucher avec vous car
elle vous prend pour Gad Elmaleh
qu'est-ce que vous faites
garde et le Malet
est arrivé apparemment elle a couché
non calme-toi c'est pas là ça doit être
difficile parce que physiquement on a
pas je sais pas super proche non Gad
Elmaleh et nous mais dis donc moi j'y
vais quand même moi aussi je ramène
entendu c'est bon aussi et après je lui
conseille un opticien une femme superbe
coucher avec vous elle vous propose même
un million d'euros personne ne le saura
jamais est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
direct
moi je pense que ma famille regarde et
non
de coucher pour de l'argent
en plus je sais pas il y a même pas
besoin de dire une femme superbe
et on savait
pas si on allait réussir enchanté en
vacances ensemble et je te dois toujours
1200 francs
je te rendrais jamais ton argent bah je
sais je sais toute manière
jamais déçu on continue vous trouvez
mais je te rendrais télécharge
ge
personne qui me jette de l'eau alors
si tu fais un Poutou c'est exclusé fais
gaffe va te faire un coup de trace
crache non non non
un vrai c'est bon non non non
je veux regarde ce flippant je veux une
remise une prise de chèque tu vois ce
que je veux dire ça veut dire poser mais
pas de bruit pas de bruit pas de bruit
et un petit mot gentil dans les yeux un
petit boulot
non après le message non le message
action message
tu viens tu mets comme ça
il va dire le message
[Musique]
action Jamel message qu'est-ce qu'il y a
pas sincère
oui il faut qu'il me le dise maintenant
c'est c'est toi le meilleur comique du
monde
installez-vous monsieur le ministre
Islam islam modéré Islam intempestif
c'est un beau message de l'Islam sympa
parce qu'on a toujours les l'image de
l'Islam Oui
de l'islam agressif de l'islam barbu et
tout et là il y a l'islam classe moi
j'aime bien prendre
ça génial
2 secondes c'est c'est de loin avec eux
que j'ai pris le plus de plaisir à la
télévision
bisous Islam bisous Islam bisous bisous
c'est le principal c'est ça le pire
c'est que moi je connais que ça
personnellement qui suis catholique
super je connais que des islames doux
des islams bisounours les islams se
claquent quoi
le concept que je voudrais lancer
le truc que j'aurais lancé c'est le
concept de John tell burn
que tous les beurre tous les rebeus de
France qui se reconnaîtront dans ce
terme avec de l'eau là
et bien c'était qu'on se réunisse tous
pour montrer à quel point on a la classe
non fumerait des loukoum
c'est magnifique et le jour où ça ça
sera bien fédéré on sera un mouvement
très très fort
les mœurs à ce moment là on bosse là
dessus
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on continue on
continue
vous trouvez un moyen faillite de pas
payer vos impôts qu'est-ce que vous
faites
moi ça me gêne moi de pas payer mes
enfants les impôts c'est tendus ça bah
oui parce que ça paye des écoles et des
routes et tout ça non sérieusement et
des routes qui traversent des écoles en
plus ouais
quand même c'est vrai vous voyez David
Douillet frapper un enfant pour lui
piquer des pièces jaunes qu'est-ce que
vous faites
qu'est-ce que vous faites bon le tabasse
avec lui mais on traite ah ouais
une fois que l'enfant est presque
inanimé on vient
j'ai accueille maintenant Frédéric
Beigbeder
[Musique]
c'est lui qui a
va venir
non Catherine il a bu trop de vodka mais
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va faire Catherine
un compte rendu
on va faire une consultation malade il
s'est arché dans les torcher il a bu
trop de vodka et que j'avais dit de pas
boire on peut l'aider on peut le changer
il est couché par terre dans la
logeais
non non il est couché par terre dans la
loge Catherine
en fait
catherine est pas bourré du tout bah
écoute voilà donc il était pas bien
quand on était ensemble
je l'ai trouvé un petit peu particulier
bien il peut pas venir c'est sûr
chercher
pas parler
je vis des gens me parlaient à
l'émission mais des gens venus dans la
loge et incapable de rentrer sur le
plateau
et maintenant
voici Frédéric Beigbeder
[Musique]
alors Frédéric ce trade j'ai dit des Bee
Gees c'était à la fois pour le sujet de
votre livre et à la fois pour ce qui
s'est passé la semaine dernière oui
alors la semaine dernière qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé je me souviens de rien
merci beaucoup merci
et non c'est pas de nom en plus
c'est incroyable c'est quoi de la vodka
ici on vous sert énormément de vodka
Tony et une fille très charmante très
jolie
me voir est-ce que vous voulez encore un
verre je disais oui etc et tout ça se
passait d'une manière sympathique
jusqu'au moment où je me suis dit que
j'étais trop éméché pour parler d'un
livre qui est important pour moi qui est
important
c'est grave et voilà mais c'est bien
dans la rue effectivement là tous les
gens pendant une semaine
demandez comment j'allais si je
connaissais l'aspectgicmail
donc c'est très finalement c'est c'est
une belle aventure
regarde et quand elle vous a vu tomber
dans la loge
aux gens qui nous regardent ne faites
pas ça chez vous
c'est mal il ne faut pas votre livre est
l'événement littéraire de la rentrée
vous avez décidé en plus tellement ça
marche de faire deux télés tout le monde
en parle et CNN qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
plus chic je vous le être marche arrive
c'est plus sûr le Figaro Magazine vous
appelle le nouveau BHL avant c'était
François nourrisson
même si vous n'avez pas fait de télé
depuis quelques temps vous êtes toujours
critique littéraire quand même hein au
journal voici toujours DJ dans des
soirées j'espère et vous êtes devenu
éditeur Frédéric entre temps directeur
littéraire chez Flammarion vous dites
Frédéric éditeur finalement c'est
attaché de presse de luxe ça peut être
aussi comme un portier de boîte de nuit
vous dites toi oui toi non toi reviens
dans 6 mois toi ta femme oui mais toi
non c'est un peu comme ça vous allez
avoir un prix non j'ai vu que vous étiez
sur la liste du Renault dos et du
Goncourt les alcooliques
pris du vomi non non c'est vrai que je
pensais à ça c'est que je voudrais
préciser que je n'ai absolument pas vomi
depuis une semaine aussi les gens me
disent ah c'est dégueulasse etc et en
fait le vomi c'est vachement glamour
quand c'est sur MTV Jackass mais quand
c'est moi c'est juste minable donc
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête d'en parler
j'ai une réclamation vas-y j'ai pas
tellement aimé la musique de l'entrée
j'aurais préféré la musique là un peu
sexy là qu'on entendait tout à l'heure
tu veux leur faire
merci merci c'est gentil
attention ne bouge pas Frédéric restant
au des escaliers attention j'accueille
Frédéric
énorme
c'est vachement mieux excuse-moi mais on
me dit dans l'oreillette pas un pas
c'est sensuel de il n'a pas assez joué
de la musique
il faut savoir c'est qu'aujourd'hui
Frédéric BD est un des deux auteurs les
plus vendus à l'étranger et quand on te
voit en France c'est vrai tu comprends
pourquoi
les gens qui te voient là voilà rien
pour un clown voilà pourquoi est-ce
qu'un écrivain devrait être chiant oui
parce que c'est la règle
de dandy vous êtes surnommé vous-même
mon danitore le José Bové du Flore le
gramsi de la bronchiteude et vous dites
de toute façon même si je me suicidais
on dirait que c'est un coup marketing
quoi c'est à dire que c'était victime du
succès d'un livre qui critiquait ce
système dans lequel nous vivons et que
Dominique Voynet conteste également dans
ces excès qui est le système de la
surconsommation matérialiste capitaliste
et publicitaires donc c'était un livre
satirique violent et les gens m'ont pris
pour le héros et depuis évidemment
chaque fois que je dis quoi que ce soit
de rebelle ou d'un peu révolté je suis
ridicule parce qu'en même temps
j'appartiens à ce système et j'adore ça
voilà et je crois bien vous dites que
chaque fois que je vais aller l'étranger
en me demande mon avis sur des sujets
super importants je crois qu'il me
confondent avec
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt
sinon c'est assez agréable tous ces
voyages là je reviens de ils savent pas
ils m'ont pas vu me rouler par terre
dans les boîtes et du coup je suis hyper
crédible et je peux presque tenir des
propos aussi sérieux que que ma voisine
de droite qui en réalité de gauche voilà
alors le problème effectivement c'est ce
que je disais c'est que cette image
masque un vrai succès international vous
êtes donc le romancier français le plus
vendu dans le monde avec Houellebecq
donc vous êtes vous êtes deux finalement
ce qui est pas énorme pour un pays comme
la France alors 99 francs a été traduit
dans 25 pays
Windows on the World vient de recevoir
en Angleterre le prix de l'indépendante
qui est le super prix non c'est vraiment
le truc c'est c'est une espèce de super
goncour anglais quoi voilà mais fais pas
le timide il y a le prix Nobel bien sûr
moi je suis juste en dessous humblement
très très modestement alors c'est un
prix qui est remis dans la reine
Elizabeth c'est incroyable et donc
Frédéric d'accord quand même excuse-moi
excuse-moi des desserts
c'est pas encore officiel donc je
demanderai à tous les gens qui ont vu
l'émission de ne pas le répéter
il faut savoir c'est que Windows
Underworld donc sort aux Ush et Miramax
qui est quand même pas rien Miramax
c'est les frères d'enstein quand même
d'ailleurs je crois le l'exemplaire ici
d'ailleurs il est très beau en Amérique
je reconnais que les américains ils ont
quand même c'est hard cover
[Musique]
râteau non mais c'est incroyable
en même temps il est habitué parce que
avant d'être célèbre c'était tous les
jours
Windows on the world donc publié chez
Miramax et déjà chroniqué par le
Harper's bazar le New York Time San
Francisco Chronicle donc voilà j'essaye
de dire quand même une chose
nul n'est prophètes en sont pays
finalement
c'est c'est c'est ça des explications je
veux dire vraiment moi j'assume la
responsabilité de mes actes j'ai pas
j'ai pas une biographie qui correspond
au cliché au stéréotypes de l'écrivain
modèle en France ça baisse modeste non
plus et c'est vrai que voilà c'est
Flaubert dans sa dans sa ferme Marcel
Proust dans sa chambre tapissé de Liège
non moi c'est plutôt c'est plutôt
les râteaux
c'est un autre esprit mais en 20 minutes
sur la défensive
mais souvent j'ai remarqué si tu tu
annonces la couleur tu prends un râteau
et la fille quelquefois elle se dit oh
zut elle se met à regretter pas tout le
temps quelques fois
elle se dit après finalement lui au
moins il a essayé alors que les autres
pas donc
mais non je dis ça en l'air hein
tout à fait Thierry qui s'appelle
l'égoïste romantique donc c'est le
journal de votre hétéronyme
oscar Dufresne ça veut dire ça veut dire
un homonyme hétérosexuel
on est soit au menu quand on aime les
garçons soit été renime quand on aime
les filles c'est un homony avec un autre
nom et c'est pratique parce que quand on
veut parler de soi le meilleur moyen
c'est de se déguiser de mettre un masque
et c'est ce que j'ai fait avec ce livre
voilà voilà alors vous dites
Oscar c'est celui qu'on croit être
Frédéric Beigbeder et en fait dans le
livre vous êtes plutôt Ludo le marié que
que
Oscar Oscar c'est un peu votre votre
rêve d'homme d'une certaine façon c'est
un peu aussi le fantasme de tous les
peut-être de tous les hommes de ma
génération c'est-à-dire voilà il est
très cynique très riche célèbre beaucoup
de succès avec les femmes c'est lâche
aussi égoïste obsédé sexuel bien sûr un
type normal somme toute et donc c'est
très défoulant et en même temps très
tragique comme destin puisque au fond ce
type là il est paumé il est pas heureux
du tout et si on lit bien le livre
vraiment attentivement avec les sujets
les verbes les compléments on
s'apercevra que c'est une tragédie alors
l'égoïste romantique c'est un oxymoron
oxymoron tranquille la force tranquille
c'est un oxymoron qui vont pas ensemble
je sais pas comme un nain géant voilà
[Musique]
sur pattes mais oui parce que égoïste
euh
tout le monde l'est peut-être et
d'autres de plus en plus dans un monde
d'individualisme et cetera et en même
temps ça serait plus simple si on était
vraiment en réalité on est également
romantique c'est-à-dire que vous dites
c'est les hommes sont pas seulement
guidés par le sexe ça serait trop simple
il y a les couilles
c'est important
c'est pas ça qui veut dire alors ce qui
veut dire c'est que Bridget se trompe en
pensant que les hommes ne sont ne sont
mus que par le sexe ça serait trop
facile évidemment il y a aussi toute une
part romantique chez l'homme qui est
beaucoup plus dangereux d'ailleurs bien
sûr les hommes tombent amoureux envoient
des fleurs écrivent des lettres d'amour
et c'est beaucoup plus douloureux ce
serait plus simple si c'était que
physique vous en déduisez Frédéric BD
l'impossibilité du couple comme disait
Aragon il n'y a pas d'amour heureux donc
voilà l'homme étant égoïste et
romantique mais le couple ne peut pas
marcher et d'autant moins dans une
époque où tout a volé en éclat
c'est-à-dire que depuis les années 60
liberté sexuelle
veut dire contraception divorce facilité
plus de famille plus de religion les 35
heures le RMI enfin bref tout explique
l'explosion du couple non c'est vrai
qu'il y a
alors un moment il dit je ne vois plus
le couple comme une prison mais comme un
port d'attache moi je suis un optimiste
je suis pour que ça marche et je suis un
désastre ambulant avec qui va d'échec en
échec j'en suis absolument pas fier et
tout à fait un livre qui t'a porté
malheur au départ c'est l'amour dure
trois ans c'est une malédiction c'est
une malédiction que tu as maintenant
mais malheureusement autour de moi je
déplore de vérifier très souvent
alors le problème de la génération
Beigbeder effectivement c'est qu'elle
est nourrie de deuxième degré
d'autodérision c'est l'époque des des
anti-héros la fin des idéologies la
destruction des valeurs et c'est vrai on
voit bien parce que le héros de son
bouquin oscar Dufresne quand même faut
dire que son rêve absolu dans la vie
c'est de partir sur une île avec trois
mannequins la chatte épilée franchement
c'est un idéal imbécile quoi c'est un
anti-héros de même que que Meursault ou
requin c'est ce que j'aime c'est les
loosers sur facebook beaucoup plus
sympathique un héros qui est qui est nul
qui qui a des désirs nus qui est perdu
et qui en même temps voudrais être
heureux parce qu'il je pense qu'il
ressemble un peu à chacun de nous quand
même il est trop mignon en fait oh
voilà alors au-delà de tout ça il y a
évidemment un style un style impeccable
c'est clair que vous avez le sens de la
formule demandez une fille en mariage il
y a pas mieux pour meubler une
conversation c'est c'est vrai en plus
le problème c'est les conséquences après
mais
en même temps
[Musique]
je me suis couché des bonheur enfin il y
a des il y a des il y a des phrases
rigolotes il y en a une quand la femme
n'est pas niquée elle est paniquée enfin
c'est pas de vous c'est d'Oscar je pense
que Béatrice a prouve
[Rires]
souvent
là où un autre auteur plus prestigieux
et plus académique peut-être
hésiteraient moi j'y vais parce que je
crois que c'est la différence entre toi
et Troya
moi j'y vais tant pis c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être un peu lourdo mais c'est
une réalité c'est une réalité je suis
désolé en même temps c'est vrai
j'ai une question si c'était pas vous
qui l'aviez écrit vous le conseilleriez
à moi par exemple oui
vous dites aussi plus je gagne de
l'argent moi ma vie est enrichissante
ben c'est vrai sérieusement les gens se
rendent pas compte mais c'est pas facile
d'être c'est vrai que là on a vendu
vraiment le truc comme une révolution de
la syntaxe littéraire quoi un vrai un
vrai truc ambitieux
sont toujours entre une ex et une future
entre la nostalgie et l'espoir coincé
entre deux absences
c'est c'est le problème de la gente
masculine d'avoir besoin de conquérir de
voyager de
séduire et peut-être moins que les
femmes de construire d'être équilibré
c'est une folie qu'on a et évidemment ce
qui se passe
je crois que c'est vrai aussi
et je voudrais dire c'est j'adore la
légèreté mais je pense je pense comme la
au-dessus que la gravité et la racine de
la légèreté et que ce et que il faut pas
s'arrêter à la surface
paillette
débile de ce genre de prestation parce
qu'en réalité je crois que c'est mon
livre le plus intime et le plus sincère
voilà maintenant parlons d'autre chose
il faut refaire l'entrée emmener
c'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant
on va faire une interview Alain Delon
pour vous Frédéric Beigbeder synonyme de
quoi
alors ça dépend dans quel pays en
Lituanie c'est synonyme d'orgasme
mais si vous prenez si vous prenez
l'Ukraine la Biélorussie et le aussi le
sud de la Bulgarie alors là c'est
synonyme de dollars de dollars contre
contre des services
est-ce que vous pensez c'est un bateau
là
Dominique t'imagines
en français le plus vendu à l'étranger
j'ai rien fait pour une fois j'ai rien
fait je veux pas te laisser faire tu as
bien raison et moi
j'en suis bouche bée
[Musique]
c'est pas en train d'essayer il faut pas
arrêter de croire que je suis gros
accent Brice ou c'est bon
je cours plus vite sans lui
est-ce que vous pensez que Frédéric un
grand écrivain
Frédéric Beigbeder en est persuadé mais
oscar Dufresne n'est pas d'accord
est-ce que Frédéric Beigbeder atteint
aujourd'hui une certaine sérénité
Frédéric Beigbeder
cherche la sagesse
il essaie d'être honnête c'est déjà un
début bien sûr mais la sérénité à mon
avis n'est il la trouvera jamais jamais
non jamais jamais jamais jamais jamais
jamais dans le coma voilà voilà d'accord
est-ce que c'est vrai on dit qu'il
faudrait ces derniers temps on aurait
passé beaucoup de temps avec des top
models dans des boîtes topless
alors on raconte Frédéric Beigbeder à ce
genre de vie c'est très exagéré très
exagéré
les photographies qui circulent en ce
moment sur le net sont de grossier photo
montage d'accord voilà
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faudrait
beaucoup à son physique
non
[Rires]
personne n'a remarqué mais c'est moi qui
l'ai foutu un râteau là j'ai rien
demandé je suis désolé
une trace dans la littérature
Frédéric Beigbeder
on prononce souvent deux mots que j'aime
bien qui sont Frédéric et Beigbeder
une trace n'est pas le but ultime d'un
écrivain il est de formuler des émotions
de peut-être immortaliser des instants
éphémères mais pas nécessairement de
s'immortaliser lui-même
c'est énorme comment ça se fait attendez
attendez il est tôt
est-ce que Frédéric beigbedy est fier de
faire fantasmer 3 milliards de femmes
alors
qu'on revienne sur cette statistique
parce que la planète donc il y a 6
milliards d'habitants vous m'arrêter si
je me trompe mais il y a plus de femmes
que d'hommes donc c'est plutôt 3
milliards et demi de femmes fantasmes
sur Frédéric
aimerait bien mais ce n'est pas le cas
en Russie oui
en Allemagne mais alors pas du tout du
tout au Japon c'est très très il y a un
gros problème au Japon il faut
absolument faire quelque chose si on
pouvait lancer un appel est-ce que TV5
diffuse l'émission au Japon
je suis traduit au Japon mais alors
c'est un bide total ah oui oui absolu
[Rires]
le film de Sophia Coppola j'adorerais
t'as pas remarqué les normes feeling
là là je peux vous dire Nicolas le
jardinier va te rhabiller
voici Gwen Stéphanie
là déjà
bonsoir bonsoir
je suis scotché ça fait ça fait trois
ans que je vous attends
stéphanie a déclaré je suis juste une
fille de Orange County qui fait de la
musique avec ses amis il y a pas de quoi
faire toutes ces histoires mais en fait
il y a ça quand même Didier
[Musique]
ah oh oh oh
oh
[Musique]
Gwen Stefani
Gwen ses amis avec le groupe Noga
et elle est toujours avec 4 jeunes
filles
elles sont magnifiques mais elles
bougent pas une oreille Gwen Stefani
elle est géniale
elle est formidable
mais tous ces clips sont magnifiques la
nouvelle grande star mondiale on est
très heureux de vous avoir mais ces
personnes derrière elles sont très
inquiétantes quand même hein
vous faites quoi après
c'est mon rêve en fait je suis étonnée
que vous arrivez les voir vous les voyez
vraiment
c'est un rêve j'étais pas au courant
vous les voyez aussi japanes
comment tu la trouves Gwen Stefani
Guillaume
depuis très longtemps j'adore sa voix
j'adore ces clips j'adore on a tous
envie
je suis un comique vulgaire
je suis le comique le plus vulgaire en
France voilà
vous avez remarqué Gwen que je vous ai
pas parlé de votre vie privée je vous ai
pas demandé la dernière fois que vous
êtes disputé avec Gavin je suis très
discret vous vous remarquez à quel point
je suis discret
ravi merci beaucoup
de respect dans cette émission vraiment
merci on est très discret vous avez
remarqué on est très discret ceci étant
vous aimez bien les ragots vous aussi
quand quand Bruce Willis s'engueule avec
Demi Moore ou quand Kate Winslet se
sépare de son jules ça vous intéresse
vous comprenez pourquoi on s'intéresse à
Gwen et à Gavin en même temps
vraiment vous allez me poser des
questions sur ce sujet non merci je vais
pas vous poser des questions sur le
sujet parce que je sais que ça vous
embête et moi j'ai aucune envie de vous
embêter
est-ce que est-ce que vous allez
retravailler avec nos docks
que j'ai fait comme ça c'était sympa
alors on va faire une interview now down
[Musique]
alors Gwen est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
des doutes sur la qualité des chansons
de votre album
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des doutes
sur votre capacité à faire une carrière
solo
encore une fois je crois pas que ça soit
vraiment un album en solo c'est juste un
projet alors oui j'ai déjà eu des doutes
c'est un site
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des doutes
sur votre talent
es que je pose moi
c'est ma passion lorsque j'ai découvert
que je pouvais le faire et bien je me
suis découverte donc j'en suis
dépendante et j'adore faire ça vous avez
déjà eu des doutes sur la fidélité de
votre mec
vous savez où il est là tonight
comme ça il est fort il est fort il est
en bas des escaliers là il est prêt à
venir il est prêt à venir avec ses
bandes
il est où ce dernier
comment gagner une commande alors
il a peur que il dit qu'il a peur que je
lui casse la gueule mais non
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des doutes
sur la présence d'armes de destruction
massive en
irake
j'écris des chansons
je viens de Californie j'ai grandi à
côté de Disneyland alors mon avis sur la
question
non moi j'écris des chansons est-ce que
vous avez eu des doutes sur la
réélection de George Bush
et je ne fais pas la fête là d'accord on
a compris vous avez déjà eu des doutes
sur l'existence de Dieu
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des doutes
sur l'existence des extraterrestres
vous avez déjà eu des doutes sur la
propreté des Français
[Rires]
c'est la liberté et je ne serai jamais
ici avec vous en France je ne voyagerai
pas autant si je n'étais pas aussi
célèbre et c'est ce que j'aime j'aime la
liberté parce que ça me permet de créer
et je suis infiniment reconnaissante à
toutes ces personnes qui vont m'ont
permis d'être là
[Musique]
merci
voilà
direction en bois j'adore
comment tu la trouves alors
c'est incroyable parce que tu vois là je
me rends compte que je suis devenu vieux
ou non
existence
mais
elle a l'air de d'être bien entouré
parce que elle a des clips d'enfer et
puis la bonne musique en plus tu vois
mais faut voir au plumard vraiment
j'accueille maintenant Didier Lestrade
[Musique]
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste à TÊTU
co-fondateur de l'acteur vous avez déjà
publié deux livres chez de Noël dont
acteur une histoire et vous publiez
aujourd'hui Diane toujours chez de Noël
vous partez d'un Costa simple depuis
l'arrivée des trithérapies en 1996 le
sida ne fait plus peur c'est ce qui
explique le phénomène du verbac alors le
derbach pour nos amis téléspectateurs
qui ne seraient pas au courant c'est
l'abandon de la capote c'est c'est un
nouveau style de vie après 25 ans
d'épidémie ou des gens sont fatigués de
la capote et ils finissent par
revendiquer le fait de refuser la capote
et je crois que ce livre c'est un c'est
la première fois qu'on fait un livre sur
la prévention en milieu gay parce que je
suis très inquiet de ça c'est quelque
chose qui après 15 ans de d'activisme me
fait beaucoup de mal et de voir que
l'épidémie reprend chez les homosexuels
c'est forcément un moment bien sûr c'est
un sujet grave mais c'est un moment
c'est quelque chose c'est un sujet qui
mérite quand même consensurge et non
seulement à l'intérieur de son propre
groupe c'est-à-dire que moi je me suis
toujours battu dans la lutte contre le
sida et je suis un peu triste quand je
vois que les choses commencent à tourner
mal quoi oui quand on lit votre bouquin
on a l'impression c'est un peu rien ne
va plus chez les homos la communauté
perd ses repères quoi c'est un peu
excusez-moi il y a plus de morale quoi
les jeunes par exemple qui arrivent à 20
ans ils ont pas vraiment connu ce qu'on
a connu nous moi je suis sur repos
depuis 17 ans et c'est vrai que même
quelqu'un de mon âge c'est très
difficile de parler à un jeune et de
leur expliquer en quoi c'est vraiment
important de rester sur renégatif et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour se
protéger et c'est vrai que moi ça fait
depuis 5 ans 6 ans que je vois cette
idée de berbach grandir de plus en plus
dans la communauté gay et à un moment on
a cru que c'était un fantasme c'était un
délire de ma part et je crois que
maintenant on a des chiffres qui
montrent que d'année en année ça
augmente dans tous les pays qui sont
autour de chez nous et je crois que 20%
d'augmentation en Angleterre l'année
dernière pour une seule année ça veut
dire que il suffit 5 ans comme ça et on
double le nombre de cas de sida les
barbecker pour vous c'est un petit peu
des kamikazes quoi des kamikazes ni
listes qui disent après moi le déluge il
y a une partie des gens qui ont vraiment
envie d'être
euh d'être une liste oui mais il y a
aussi des gens tout simplement qui
bossent les bras qui baissent les bras
parce que c'est vraiment très dur de
considérer que tous les jours il faut
mettre la capote et je crois que la
prévention était vraiment dans une
situation vraiment de crise en France
c'est à dire que les associations je
crois ont baissé la garde vraiment et je
crois que l'État en profitent et que du
coup à partir du moment par le pas de
prévention et bien les gens sont des
emparés ils savent vraiment pas ce qu'il
faut faire le sentiment qu'on a digérer
si vous voulez mettre une morale dans
tout ça et on revient un petit peu sur
la problématique que développer Soral
ici la semaine dernière c'est à dire il
y a une homosexualité subversive et une
homosexualité normative et vous êtes
plutôt partisan de la seconde mais non
parce que j'ai 46 ans j'ai fait partie
de
l'homosexualité subversive mais c'était
avant l'arrivée du sida ça va être
subversif aujourd'hui quand il y a 42
millions de personnes qui sont touchées
par cette maladie c'est quand même pas
possible on s'est battu moi je me suis
battu pendant 13 ans pour qu'il y ait
des traitements j'ai rencontré tous les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques en fait
c'est mon travail est acteur j'ai fait
chier l'élaborateurs pharmaceutiques et
le gouvernement et maintenant qu'on a
les traitements qu'on est dans un pays
où on a la chance d'avoir les
traitements il y a des mecs qui veulent
être subversifs en disant je vais
oublier la capote c'est pas de la
subversion c'est tout simplement de la
connerie et un moment il faut le
rappeler que c'est non seulement un
respect de soi-même mais un respect des
autres
alors
j'étais un petit peu déçu c'est le
sentiment qu'on a en lisant votre livre
déçu parce que finalement dans la
communauté gay l'individualisme a
remplacé l'idéalisme je crois oui un peu
mais je crois que c'est un peu le
principe d'immersion je crois qu'il faut
que les gens aient mal pour qu'ils se
ressaisissent et je crois que c'est ce
qui s'est passé au début du sida vous
savez les gens se sont mobilisés au
début du sida parce qu'ils avaient peur
les gens se sont pas pris la capote
parce que c'était fun ils ont pris la
capote tout simplement parce qu'ils
avaient vraiment peur de mourir et je
crois que maintenant les gens oublient
ce que c'est cette maladie moi-même il
suffit de voir mon visage il est marqué
tout ça mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que vous voyez plus maintenant des
images de malade à la télé vous envoyez
plus à la dans les journaux et à partir
du moment où les trithérapies sont
arrivés c'est vrai qu'on a commencé à
dire bon ben les médias ont été contents
de considérer que c'est un sujet qu'on
pouvait mettre de côté pour pouvoir
parler d'autre chose
cet enthousiasme qui avait au départ
vous dites par exemple la banalisation
du sexe vous citez de un exemple dans
votre bouquin vous arrivez dans un mini
bar cuir il y a un mec qui est en train
de sucer à un autre en se faisant
[__] il continue à discuter comme si
de rien n'était vous dites que
finalement une espèce de banalisation du
truc quoi que ce n'est même plus glamour
il y a surtout des rapports qui sont
plus difficiles maintenant entre
homosexuel et je crois que c'est le fond
du problème c'est le fond de ce livre
pourquoi l'épidémie reprend chez les
homosexuels c'est parce que je crois que
ils sont très durs les uns envers les
autres et ce ils ont des systèmes de
drague maintenant qui sont vraiment qui
passent pas par le dialogue qui passe
pas par on n'a pas envie de savoir qui
c'est on n'a pas envie de se connaître
il y a vachement de mains qui ont
vraiment très peur de tomber amoureux
aujourd'hui c'est quand même le monde à
l'envers c'est la culture du backroom
quoi on y va pour baiser c'est la
culture du sexe qui est disponible qui
est bien mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que ça a eu un effet un peu pervers
c'est à dire que cette banalisation du
sexe a fait maintenant les gens ont
vraiment du mal à communiquer et je
crois que enfin on le sait que c'est
bien mais c'est quand même juste un
moyen quand même l'idée c'est quand même
de pouvoir se rencontrer et de pouvoir à
un moment quand vous avez peur de parler
à quelqu'un parce que vous avez
l'impression que vous parlez trop ou
peut-être vous dites pas les choses
qu'il faut faire je veux dire ça veut
dire que les rapports de drague et les
rapports de communication commencent à
être un peu un peu perverti je crois
vous en pensez quoi Gérard cette espèce
de pourrait dire des fondrement des
valeurs d'une certaine façon enfin les
valeurs homosexuelles en tous les cas
des valeurs de la communauté gay on
parle des bacromes des choses comme ça
je pense que c'est très parisien et très
citadin il y a plein de gens qui savent
parce que c'est donc il y a aussi des
homosexuels qui qui sont pas dans les
bacrumes
et des bains et des machins et qui
s'aiment et qui et qui font l'amour
normalement quoi il y a pas un ghetto
autant de ghetto qu'on peut penser voilà
ce que je veux dire à partir du moment
si vous savez dans un mois il va y avoir
les premiers chiffres officiels de leur
dire
si dans un mois vous avez une remontée
vraiment effectivement de l'épidémie
chez homosexuelle que vous alliez dans
les bacs promocoa tout le monde sera
vraiment concerné par en fait c'est vrai
qu'il y a une façon simple d'être
homosexuel et la façon d'acte qui était
très militante trop militante attendez
on n'a jamais été trop militant
n'oubliez pas qu'en France on a réussi à
influencer la distribution des
médicaments qui ont sauvé des dizaines
de milliers de vie et vous pouvez dire
il y a bien sûr acteur ne peut pas être
bon et d'ailleurs je passe une grande
partie de mon bouquin à les critiquer
mais ce que je veux dire en tout cas sur
les traitements on a fait un boulot qui
est vraiment exemplaire dans le monde
exemplaire José Bové de la capote mais
oui c'est pour ça je l'admire bien avec
quelqu'un que vous admirez pas du tout
hein c'est Eric reymes
ben oui parce que je crois que c'est
d'un des deux un des deux écrivains
homosexuels qui a fait qui a basé sa
carrière sur le fait de dire que
abandonner la capote était plutôt fun et
moi en tant que militant je ne peux pas
accepter ça je suis obligé de me mettre
en colère il est là voici Eric Rennes
[Musique]
auteur notamment de serial fucker
journal d'un berreberker en 2003 aux
éditions blanches où vous expliquez
comment plomber un partenaire tout à
fait donc ça c'était un roman donc je
suis venu il y a un an et demi expliqué
les problèmes du Barback dans la
communauté gay j'ai fait mon j'ai fait
mon devoir de renseignements et de
d'informations je suis journaliste donc
depuis 15 ans je bossais à guêpier quand
Didier était à guepier aussi après j'ai
fait les articles dans je suivais les
actes d'actope pour pour Libération donc
j'ai toujours fait un travail de
prévention c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment
on pouvait vous soupçonner de faire
l'apologie du verbe bac en expliquant
exactement comment il fallait faire pour
couper le bout de la capote pour faire
un trou avec une aiguille pour être sûr
de contaminer son partenaire et
aujourd'hui vous dites en fait j'ai fait
tout ça pour pour
raison de prévention en fait c'est un
travail de journaliste que j'avais fait
aussi je dis ce qui se passe exactement
dans certaines backroom comme Didier le
fait voilà mais en fait d'accord mais
non c'est trop facile d'écrire des trucs
dans les bouquins et de passer à la télé
pour dire c'est juste un roman je veux
dire tous les [__] qui commencent et
connaissent Éric cremess vont sur son
site et c'est qu'il est il sait ce qu'il
a écrit il a encore donné une interview
à un an ou disait que ça fait plusieurs
années qu'il baisait sans capote qui
choper toutes les MST du monde que ceux
qui se sont contaminés et qui disait
grosso modo que c'était tout à fait cool
j'ai le droit de parler de de ce qui me
plaît aussi tu as baisé sans capote et
dans le cas tu es alors beaucoup de
militants actes ont baisé sans capote
aussi je suis pas là pour parler du sida
de toute façon je suis en plus je
préfère pas parler avec Didier Lestrade
puisque il y a pourquoi parce que dans
la mesure où je parle pas aux fasciste
de manière générale
[Musique]
il y a une procédure parce que Act Up a
saccager les bureaux de mon éditeur des
éditions blanches et donc il y a une
procédure en cours donc je veux pas je
passe je veux pas parler de ça quoi il y
a un schisme dans la communauté un grave
ah mais c'est trop facile ça c'est trop
facile c'est à dire que pendant des
années vous savez à chaque fois que j'ai
sorti un bouquin il me disait merci
d'avoir parlé de moi parce que tu as
fait ma promo donc il faut pas être
aussi cynique que ça c'est à dire le mec
il a fait vraiment son beurre sur le
berbach il y a des gens qui ont lu ces
bouquins et il y a sûrement des gens qui
sont devenus séropositif aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils sont tellement désemparés
qu'ils ont pensé que c'était une option
possible d'affronter le sida en se
contant minant d'une manière voulue et
maintenant on est en train de dire que
c'est des romans mais c'est trop facile
même discours que tu as mais il est
toujours le même
j'ai toujours dit la même chose
moi
aussi Didier vous conviendrez que en
dehors des des romans et notamment
sérieux le fucker le le roman de notre
ami MS le plus grand sexe shop guide
Paris
[Musique]
je suis un révolutionnaire du sexe un
libérateur de la sexualité c'est pour ça
que j'ai écrit des guides sur la
sexualité ça fait 15 ans que je parle de
sexualité là je sors un nouveau bouquin
qui s'appelle le sexe guide ça fait 450
pages sur les 450
et la ferme quand on entend ce que
j'entends je suis bien atterré qu'un mec
disent moi je baise sans capote et je
suis content de le dire on peut pas
inviter Stéphanie Fugain pour parler de
la leucémie on peut pas parler du
Sidaction et laisser parler un mec non
laissez parler un mec qui ose dire moi
je baise sans capote et j'en suis fier
et j'ai le droit de penser moi je trouve
ça une honte et j vous êtes un bel
[__]
je crois que je crois qu'en témoignant à
la télé en ayant le courage aussi de
dire ce que je dis et d'informer les
gens c'est une manière de prévenir donc
si vous déguisez un peu vous a priori
c'est votre gagne-pain et vous déguisez
ça monsieur parle de prévention vous
faites du fric sur moi c'est de la
prévention radicale
mais non pas du tout expliquant que tu
as fait des choses qu'il fallait
vraiment pas faire ça passe à la
prévention
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est
d'après la réalité
en racontant ce qui se passe dans les
bacrumes moi je le j'en ai parlé il y a
un an et demi en en faisant un roman
mais c'est la même chose
et si oui est-ce que tu sais que tu as
contaminé d'autres personnes moi je suis
marié avec un mec qui s'est renégatif
depuis trois ans on essaie et je l'ai
pas contaminé il y a pas de problème
j'ai pas envie de te parler
depuis deux ans tu l'as dit dans une
autre interview faut savoir et puis de
toute façon attends le bouquin que tu as
sorti sur le black c'était il y a un an
et puisque tu as fait dans les années
précédentes on va pas commencer à te
demander vraiment si ta contaminé les
gens mais commence pas à dire que c'est
des trucs du genre c'est une histoire
ancienne il y a des gens qui sont ces
repositifs aujourd'hui et tu devrais tu
peux pas tout simplement considérer que
c'est un coup que tu as eu il y a 10 ans
ou même il y a 5 mois j'ai informé si tu
te demandes si vous avez euh
j'ai pas contaminé des gens
est-ce que vous avez contaminé des gens
sciemment et ça je m'avais parlé la
dernière c'est le nom voilà comment tu
peux dire un truc
je vous écoute et inconsciemment non
plus bien
et maintenant on passe au musée
[Applaudissements]
ça se passe que j'ai parce que je sais
pas je suis crevé c'est la première fois
que ça me fait ça
fait deux trois jours là je vois je vois
tout trouble
vous les voyez là bien sûr il y a deux
éléphants roses et derrière tu as des
iguanes qui comptent des œufs
sont en train de s'embrasser ça me
rassure même Leclerc Thierry il y en a
une demi-douzaine
[Musique]
costard de star [__]
j'ai vu le train de vie du mec les
bagnoles et tous les gonzesses il y a un
créneau là il y avait personne à son
enterrement à
renauds qui sont tous rebelles pour pas
être récupérés par le système ils sont
venus le lendemain tu as changé quoi
les cheveux oui et puis les
plaquettes tu as toujours ton Poulbot
tatouer sur l'épaule bah oui pour
toujours tu regrettes pas des choses
quand tu prends ta douche d'avoir ça sur
l'épaule non non
j'ai pas que ça en plus
ça lui fait de la lecture à ta femme
alors tu es tu as dit en fait que tu as
changé ton look parce que tu voyais des
Renault partout quoi c'est à dire que tu
dis par exemple que tu avais un foulard
rouge autour du cou tu le mettais au
poignet 15 jours après au premier rang
il y avait 15 mecs avec des foulards
rouges c'est ça ouais non c'est pas faut
que pour ça non mais c'est vrai que
c'était un peu agaçant ce phénomène
d'identification des mecs pour prouver
qui t'aimais il s'habiller comme toi
au bout d'un moment
moi même j'étais une caricature ou je
sais pas si c'était eux ou moi tu vois
les mecs me voyaient dans la rue
regarde-le habiller comme Renault
j'ai donné du mal pour être star
maintenant que tu es start tu as l'air
de vivre assez Malte à célébrité
finalement pas du tout
par exemple je garde mon casque de moto
le plus longtemps possible sur la tête
mais j'aime pas publiques
tu as dit je serai plus à l'aise
finalement si je chantais à l'abri des
oreilles un peu comme ça je serai plus
tranquille quoi à l'abri des braves
voilà l'abri de l'argent et des oreilles
le journaliste qui me posait des
questions m'avait dit
ça vous gêne pas de chanter puis que
vous dise deviennent des vos chansons
deviennent des produits et que vous-même
vous soyez un produit de consommation
de l'industrie quoi du capitalisme tout
ça j'ai dit que peut-être quelque part
au fond de mon subconscient j'aurais
préféré tu vois vivre dans un pays
totalitaire et chanter des chansons à
l'ombre d'une cave à l'abri des oreilles
de la mini de la milice total
on a fait une expérience on t'a remis
papa toi mais dans sosie on t'a remis
dans l'ambiance de la bohème tu vas voir
aussi costard de star
s vous cherchez quoi madame le concert
de Renaud
il passe ici fontaine Saint-Michel c'est
la mer qui prend l'eau
elle m'a pris je me souviens un mardi
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression qu'il a changé
beaucoup quoi ça fait de la peine de le
voir dans le creux de la bague
aujourd'hui du coup
je vais voir ça fait vraiment chier j'ai
vraiment les boules parce que [__]
il y a personne
c'est trop fort aussi tu penses que
Bruel lui a piqué un peu tous ses fans
ils sont cons à côté ce genre de musique
on s'en fout de Bruel
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
vous lui dites parce que il est dans le
creux de la vague que vous l'aimez
beaucoup et que vous allez acheter son
prochain album
euh maintenant c'est pas vrai je vais
pas là
je suis toujours pas convaincu vous êtes
le vrai chantez un peu pour voir
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
chante à vous de choisir ça alors là
c'est pas qui prend la mer c'est la mer
qui prend l'or ça vous rappelle quelque
chose vous avez une petite pièce pour
lui ah ben j'ai pas de porte monnaie sur
moi avec une carte bleue il prend tout
je suis très content de vous rencontrer
mon chien c'est plus qu'une merde
maintenant
là vous allez un peu
forte en français ou en étranger on sait
pas mais on comprend bien vous voulez
bien signer sa pétition contre le
réchauffement de la planète
alors
venir à la maison un jour tu sais pas où
dormir il est devenu pauvre
bah ça marche pas du tout si on a le
album et là il va faire une tournée dans
le métro ou lui demander un autographe
aujourd'hui
vous êtes dur avec lui
et vous le faites travailler dur comme
ça tout le temps
[Musique]
on a les cassettes
je peux pas tourner la page un bon coup
j'en peux plus franchement
j'y pense tout le temps ce truc
bistro cancer du tronc ah il y avait
quelque chose de pas mal dans cette
séquence il parlait de Van Gogh non
c'est pas ça justement
ce soir qui est venu avec ton bouquet de
cactus je te laisse avec tes cactus
le monde entier est un cactus il est
impossible
tu as dit en 27 ans
j'ai bu comme un homme normal en trois
siècles pas mal quand même ouais j'ai dû
boire pour transfert pour trois siècles
et tu buvais quoi particulièrement
je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire de tout mais
du matin au soir
toutes sortes de choses tu veux tout
savoir une recette comme ça il y a pas
de recette le Slinger par exemple ça se
fait comment Slinger c'est du faux de la
menthe fraîche faut du cognac et puis du
budget de mes blancs tu vois
et ça te glisse parfaitement mon
principe c'est un 20 ça devient autre
chose
entre le whisky le champagne
tu t'es arrêté du jour au lendemain en
plus mais la seconde
cure
d'ailleurs pourquoi parce que tu le
supportes très mal 4 mois après parce
que tout le monde admire au début je
crois que le courage il a quel volonté
machin et petit à petit quand tu
commandes de l'autre et jamais servi tu
aperçois que tu as l'air d'un coup que
des gens c'est je peux avoir oui ça
arrive monsieur non mais après tu
risques de tomber dans un état plus ou
moins je veux pas dire dépressif et
quand même tu payes la note quoi tu
avais les le foie qu'elle a explosé
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
j'ai battu les records
ridicule non mais si tu veux j'ai arrêté
comme a fait James Dean quoi vraiment où
il fallait
j'étais en train de
combien un truc comme ça oh ça vaut le
prix d'un repas
ça fume combien par jour le plus
possible ça fait de l'effet
pour les autres oui parce que
il y a une vanne que tu as pas dû
manquer de faire quand tu tournais Van
Gogh de dû la faire c'était haut et des
bananes
de Gogh c'est un pet
pas mal alors en fonction des Théo était
bas je vais te faire une interview à
peine down tu es prêt la plus grande
joie de ta carrière
la plus grande joie de ma carrière c'est
lorsque j'ai eu un gala d'annuler que je
suis rentré à 8h pour lire les pieds
nickel
dans la chambre d'hôtel merdique la plus
grande déception c'est d'essayer de se
masturber que les Pieds Nickelés
le plus grand moment de ta vie c'est
maintenant oh
le pire moment de ta vie fais gaffe
parce que tu dis ça va être après
et chez Françoise alors est-ce que tu
préfères chez Françoise rien oh
maintenant c'est un tout je veux dire
ce que tu détestes chez Françoise
c'est côté paperasse un peu
plus comptable que moi
je rentrerai pas dans les
signe astrologique moi qui croyais qu'on
avait parlé d'astrologie monsieur Dutron
mais vous pouvez
phrases que tu dis comme ça des fois
j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que tu en penses que des
phrases définitives et tragiques tu dis
entre guillemets j'aimerais tellement
avoir envie de quelque chose ça veut
dire quoi que le matin tu te lèves et tu
as envie de rien
déjà j'ai envie de me lever c'est déjà
pas mal c'est beaucoup de gens restent
dans le lit mais il faut que j'aille
faire ceci non je me lève et c'est ça
qui est terrible c'est que après je
tourne tu vois au cinéma bien sûr et
puis par moment d'accord tu aimes bien
tu aimes bien comme tu sais pas très
bien ce que tu as tu dis par exemple
j'aime bien avoir mal aux dents parce
que moi tu sais où tu as mal
c'est bizarre quand même non
ah oui mais ça c'est on rejoint un état
un état où tout va pas très très bien et
c'est insidieux c'est sournois on ne
sait pas exactement et dans ce coup
parfois on a mal à la dent on dit tiens
je sais que j'ai mal je sais où j'ai mal
et là tu es content tu sais où tu as mal
je vais ravi chez le dentiste j'ai
essayé
vous avez l'air bizarre
et tu dis aussi la vie c'est vraiment
des aphorismes la vie c'est faire
semblant de ne pas être mort
c'est-à-dire quoi rien ah bon
ton canular le plus réussi
et à l'époque où on mettait les
chaussures
côté des portes ça pourrait faire
nettoyer j'envoyais mon secrétaire
acheter les mêmes alors soit une taille
en dessous le matin c'était génial parce
que les mecs trouvaient toujours une
explication ça doit être le chauffage
par le
gonfler les pieds je sais pas quoi faire
ça ça me faisait assez il y en a eu
d'autres ont chié tous dans un journal
et on t'appelle à porte on disait au feu
et bien entendu la personne devait
dormir donc son premier réflexe était
d'arriver pieds nus ou en pyjama et de
taper des fils et celui qui a mal tourné
il y en a pas encore justement bon on va
jouer à un jeu idiot
comme d'habitude toute façon je vais te
donner des noms de gens comme ça un peu
comme le tir au pigeon d'argile je vais
les jeter en l'air et tu vas me dire ce
que tu en penses
Zulawski par exemple bien tu en penses
que du bien ça va bien vis-à-vis de moi
bien Godard bien bien bien tout le temps
comme ça
c'est la famille donc je ne peux que la
moitié
est-ce que au moins les questions
étaient idiotes et tout ça Antoine je
mise à fleurs Antoine il a bien fait de
faire de la voile
Françoise Hardy
quoi Gainsbourg
bah écoute je crois que là il est absent
pour un peu
rendu vous étiez très lié quand même
je vais pas faire le genre sans glow
c'était mon Église c'était un ami
facette un ami
c'est un des rares d'ailleurs de par
rapport à ce métier Claude François tu
l'as connu oui je l'ai connu
maquillée et je l'ai je l'ai pas reconnu
démaquillée
parce qu'un jour il a débarqué encore je
me suis demandé qu'est-ce que c'était
que ce monsieur c'était lui c'était
Johnny Hallyday oui mais lui c'est un
pote on s'est connu on devait avoir je
sais pas qui est là 14 ans ou 13 ans à
la Trinité la grande épreuve midi minuit
la Trinité
mais elle était pareil il a pas changé
lui profondément non mais autour oui
puisque quand c'est Mad Max il est en
Mad
maxi se met au goût du jour et il est
toujours là c'est un des rares qui a une
présence
et c'est là
quoi c'est la est-ce que tu as connu
c'est là c'est pas la caméra explore le
temps là elle est venue elle est venue
dîner chez toi
elle adore le saucisson
tu trouves pas scandaleux les rumeurs
qu'on courus sur son compte
Sheila est un homme ah oui mais ça
c'était à l'époque on se faisait pas
opérer oui
MC
[Musique]
do
alors est-ce que le traducteur peut
traduire pour nos amis britanniques donc
ce que je veux c'est pas le titre de la
chanson c'est le nom de l'interprète
dans un premier temps on joue par équipe
c'est l'équipe de Zazie contre l'équipe
de Laurent Baffie et ensuite c'est
chacun pour sa gueule il y a plus d'amis
c'est l'ultra libéralisme c'est l'ultra
libéral ok même que nous contestons
néanmoins néanmoins alors mesdames
messieurs vous êtes prêts chez vous pour
jouer ici nous le sommes monsieur
Beigbeder
pouvez-vous envoyer votre premier
morceau il faut faire ça
[Musique]
c'est très émouvant
bla bla bla
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la voix
c'était les Beatles c'est pas John
Lennon c'est les Beatles
donc un point pour l'équipe de Zazie
[Applaudissements]
super content pour moi c'est mieux que
d'être d'entrée à l'Académie française
[Musique]
Frédéric tu es parfait tu as vu et c'est
le film où il y a ton sosie
mon chéri c'est très bien il faut le
doigt ah oui le doigt
[Applaudissements]
donc ça fait quoi ma petite ah ça fait
deux pour l'équipe de Laurent Baffie un
pour l'équipe de Zazie
order
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on s'entend bien dedans
c'est incroyable
complicité au fil des années c'est clair
tu sais ce que tu vas faire maintenant
tu vas mettre le morceau numéro 5
c'est très facile il suffit pour moi
d'habiller sur d'habiller
avec avec mon index
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Disiz
[Applaudissements]
merci président
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais bravo
non il est bien avant non ah oui
[Musique]
merveilleux film merveilleux clip est-ce
que c'est bien Laurent vous êtes
d'accord Catherine bonjour
allez attention le doigt M6
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a pas eu
soufflage
laissez-moi parler laissez-moi parler
objection votre honneur je vous le jure
oui sur la vie de mes enfants quand je
savais que c'était d'accord ouais mais
bon
on
dit
la version gains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait deux fois la première fois je
dis rien
[Applaudissements]
quand tu as souffert donc le point voilà
et nous sommes assis et 6 c'est à dire
qu'à l'issue à l'issue du père équipe
nous sommes dans une parfaite égalité
non
[Applaudissements]
tu sais quoi on te réveille à quelle
heure
il y a un vrai suspense et ça c'est bon
pour l'audience maintenant les gens se
demandent vraiment qui va gagner on
arrive dans le chacun pour sa gueule
donc il y a plus d'équipe chacun répond
pour ça jusqu'à
nos amis de New Order qu'à partir de
maintenant c'est chacun pour soi c'est
le Banco M6
[Musique]
Queen
absolument c'est qui Peter
le groupe de de
Iggy Pop avec les frères Ashton quand
ils étaient encore à Vitrolles c'est
très très vieux tout ça et maintenant
nous passons au Méga banco mesdames
messieurs c'est-à-dire que celui ou
celle qui va trouver sera le King ou la
Queen de la soirée MC please
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est rapide c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci et bravo
la semaine prochaine merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu